Mr. President, my company tore me of the explosion on our rig. On October 2nd. Causing massive water displacement and triggering a tsunami. They all heat the blame on me. Tom Cruise is. Digger got us into this mess. And Digger's going to dig us up. From the director of Birdman and the Revenant.
总统先生，我的公司向我隐瞒了钻井平台爆炸的消息。就在10月2日。这导致了大规模的水位移并引发了海啸。他们把责任全推到了我身上。汤姆·克鲁斯是。迪格让我们陷入了这场混乱。而迪格会把我们挖出来。来自《鸟人》和《荒野猎人》导演之手。
What would happen if I stop doing? You storm. You freeze to death. That's what? With great power. Comes great deniability. I'm not the first, Danny. Digger. See the trailer online.
如果我停止这样做会怎样？你会遭遇风暴。你会冻死。就是这样？能力越大，否认的能力也越大。我不是第一个，丹尼。迪格。在线观看预告片。
Only in the year's October 2nd. The execution was already underway when, having crossed the tuileries, I reached the gate opening onto the Place Louis Cairns. From there I saw the condemned men appear one after another on the fatal stage, only to vanish at once as the plank on which their eternal rest was to begin tip them from view. Danton appeared last on that stage, drenched in the blood of all his friends. Day was fading, at the foot of the dreadful structure, standing out of the end of the dreadful structure, standing out like a colossal silhouette against the sky. I saw this tribune rise up like a shade out of Dante,
就在那一年的10月2日。当我穿过杜伊勒里宫，到达通往路易凯恩广场的门口时，处决已经开始了。从那里，我看到那些被判死刑的人一个接一个地出现在致命的舞台上，但随即消失，因为他们即将开始永恒安息的木板将他们倾斜，使他们从视野中消失。丹东是最后一个出现在那个舞台上的，浑身沾满了所有朋友的鲜血。天色渐暗，在可怕的建筑脚下，矗立在可怕建筑的尽头，像天空背景下巨大的剪影。我看到这个讲坛像但丁的阴影一样升起，
half lit by the dying sun, seeming as much to be emerging from the tomb as about to enter it. Nothing could match the boldness of this revolutionary athlete's bearing. Nothing could match the formidable set of that profile defying the axe, or the expression of that head, which, about to fall, still seemed to be dictating the laws. A dreadful spectacle. Time could never erase it from my memory. Now I felt the whole force of the emotion behind Danton's last words. Terrible words, which people repeated afterwards shuddering with horror and admiration.
在垂死的阳光下半明半暗，看起来既像是从坟墓中浮现，又像是即将进入坟墓。没有什么能比得上这位革命运动员姿态的果敢。没有什么能比得上那张蔑视斧头的侧脸的坚定，或者那颗即将落下却似乎仍在口述法律的头颅的表情。多么可怕的景象。时间永远无法将其从我的记忆中抹去。现在，我感受到了丹东临终遗言背后全部的情感力量。那些可怕的话语，人们后来在恐惧和钦佩的战栗中不断重复。
Above all, don't forget, he told the executioner. Don't forget to show my head to the people. It's worth seeing. So that's one of the most famous scenes, not just in the history of the French Revolution, but in the entire history of France. It is the eyewitness account by Antoine Vassant Arnault of the execution of George Danton,
最重要的是，别忘了，他告诉刽子手。别忘了把我的头展示给人民看。它值得一看。所以，这不仅是法国大革命史上，也是整个法国历史上最著名的场景之一。这是安托万·瓦桑·阿尔诺关于乔治·丹东处决的目击者记录，
on the 5th of April 1794, and it's a scene that's been immortalized in novels, in plays, in operas and films, and unsurprisingly so, because it is the spectacle of the French revolution devouring one of its most memorable, and I think probably attractive figures, and a bulliont, larger-than-life character, Dominic, who only a year earlier seemed at the peak of his popularity, a large Falstaffian man. A lesson to us all, Dantan's fate, I think. A lesson to us all, yeah. And you're a particular admirer, aren't you, of the Franco-Polish film Dantant, which came out during the solidarity confrontation, the Trades Union in Poland, with the communist government, and starred Gerard Depard Depardieu as Dantan. I think Gerard Depard Depardier is an absolutely
发生在1794年4月5日，这一场景在小说、戏剧、歌剧和电影中被永恒化了，这并不令人惊讶，因为这是法国大革命吞噬其最令人难忘、我认为可能也是最有吸引力的人物之一的奇观，一个充满活力、超越生命的角色，多米尼克，仅仅一年前他似乎还处于受欢迎程度的巅峰，一个像福斯塔夫那样的大块头。我认为丹东的命运对我们所有人都是一个教训。对我们所有人都是一个教训，是的。而且你特别欣赏那部法波合拍电影《丹东》，它是在波兰团结工会与共产主义政府对抗期间上映的，由杰拉尔·德帕迪约饰演丹东。我认为杰拉尔·德帕迪约是一个绝对
horrendous human being and he is brilliant in this film. And in the film, because it's a portrait, it's actually a brilliant film both about the French Revolution and about the crushing of the solidarity movement in Poland, the imposition of martial law. In the film, he is the champion of moderation against extremism. He is the champion of democracy against dictatorship, which is, of course, a little bit simplistic when you look at the story of the revolution. But there is that kind of great sense of the binary, isn't there? Because of all the On the one hand, you have Maximilian Robespierre. Yeah.
可怕的人，但他在电影中表现得非常出色。在电影中，因为它是一幅肖像，这实际上是一部关于法国大革命和波兰团结运动被镇压、戒严令实施的精彩电影。在电影中，他是反对极端主义的温和派捍卫者。他是反对独裁的民主捍卫者，当然，当你审视革命的故事时，这有点简单化了。但确实有一种伟大的二元对立感，不是吗？因为所有的一切，一方面，你有马克西米连·罗伯斯庇尔。是的。
Tall, thin, cold, fanatical, obsessed by ideas of God and virtue. And on the other side, his old friend, Georges Dantan, charismatic, a man of bulk, warm, the man who wants to stop the reign of terror, the people's friend. Yeah. And that dynamic of the kind of the chill, cold, thin person and the warm, jolly, larger person. I mean, it's a kind of almost archetypal.
高、瘦、冷酷、狂热，痴迷于上帝和美德的观念。而在另一边，他的老朋友乔治·丹东，富有魅力，身材魁梧，热情，那个想要停止恐怖统治的人，人民的朋友。是的。那种冰冷、瘦削的人和热情、快乐、身材魁梧的人之间的动态。我的意思是，这几乎是一种原型。
A sturdy man of the people and the desiccated lover of abstract nouns. Yeah, completely. Yeah. So it's a jewel for the ages, but obviously there's a lot more going on because we're at the sort of crisis moment for the revolution.
一个坚强的人民代表和抽象名词的枯燥爱好者。是的，完全正确。是的。所以这是一场跨越时代的对决，但显然还有更多的事情在发生，因为我们正处于革命的某种危机时刻。
Generally war on the frontiers, war within France, loads of nuances, so we might as well get straight into it. We'll get into it with our protagonist who is d'anton. So I think you're at dead right of all the French Revolution's great character.
边境战争，法国国内战争，充满了细微差别，所以我们不妨直接进入主题。我们将从我们的主角丹东开始。所以我认为你对所有法国大革命的伟大人物的看法是完全正确的。
characters, D'Anton's probably the most magnetic. He's the one you'd go on a night out with, I think. And Depodier, shocking bloke, brilliant actor, does a really good job of capturing his appeal in that film, which I recommend to people that's on YouTube. So D'Onton is a big man, you know, stocky, famously ugly, but incredibly charismatic, energetic. He's a brilliant speaker. He's theatrical. He's generous. There's something slightly Churchillian, I think, about. him, a man of tremendous flaws, but also great magnetic qualities. Listeners may remember that I ventriloquized one of his most famous speeches and did it as Churchill. You did, exactly.
人物，丹东可能是最有吸引力的。我想他是那种你会和他一起出去过夜的人。而德帕迪约，这个令人震惊的家伙，出色的演员，在电影中很好地捕捉到了他的魅力，我向人们推荐这部电影，它在YouTube上。所以丹东是个大人物，你知道，结实，以丑陋著称，但非常有魅力，精力充沛。他是一位出色的演说家。他很有戏剧性。他很慷慨。我认为他身上有某种丘吉尔式的特质。他是一个有着巨大缺陷，但也有巨大磁性品质的人。听众可能记得我曾模仿他最著名的演讲之一，并以丘吉尔的方式演绎。你确实做到了，没错。
Don'ton can be flippant. He can be greedy. He can be very, very corrupt, as we will see. But he's hard to dislike. And he was born in a place called Arci in Champagne in 1759. So that means that he's about to turn 30 when the French Revolution breaks out. Like so many of these people, he's a relatively young man. He has a very distinctive look.
丹东可能轻浮。他可能贪婪。他可能非常、非常腐败，正如我们将要看到的。但他很难让人讨厌。他于1759年出生在香槟地区的阿尔西。这意味着法国大革命爆发时他快30岁了。像许多这些人一样，他是一个相对年轻的人。他长相非常有特色。
because as a boy, he'd been both gored by a bull and trampled by pigs. That's bad luck, isn't it? Yeah, it's very unfortunate. So his lip was spitt and his nose was all mangled, and to make it matters worse, he had smallpox. So his face is quite a spectacle. Now, his father, who was a local prosecutor, sent him to boarding school, and then he went and settled on the left bank of Paris,
因为小时候，他既被公牛顶过，又被猪踩过。那真是倒霉，不是吗？是的，非常不幸。所以他的嘴唇裂开了，鼻子也毁容了，更糟糕的是，他还得了天花。所以他的脸相当引人注目。他的父亲是一名地方检察官，把他送到了寄宿学校，然后他去巴黎左岸定居，
and he became a lawyer. He got married. He had a couple of sons. And he's a funster, really, in the late 1780s. He has lots of sort of boozy dinner parties. He's well known for them. He has lots of affairs. He's not a very good husband.
他成为了一名律师。他结婚了。他有两个儿子。在18世纪80年代末，他确实是个享乐主义者。他举办了很多那种酗酒的晚宴。他因此而闻名。他有很多婚外情。他不是一个好丈夫。
He lives life to the full. And then when the revolution breaks out, he's living there in the left bank in this district called the Coeur d'Aille, which is a real hotbed of militancy. So there's loads of people like him, young lawyers, there's artisans, stuff like that. And he's prominent in the protests around the fall of the Bastille, the summer of 1789. He becomes a sort of leading light in the district. He's hanging out with Jean-Bour-Marat, who we talked about a couple of episodes ago, and with a man called Camille de Moula, who's a great friend of his, who we will come to later on. And because D'Anne is a really good speaker, because this is a big man, he's kind of alpha male,
他充分享受生活。然后当革命爆发时，他住在左岸一个叫科德利埃的区，那里是激进主义的温床。所以那里有很多像他一样的人，年轻的律师，工匠之类的。他在1789年夏天攻占巴士底狱前后的抗议活动中很突出。他成为了该区的领军人物。他和我们几集前谈到的让-保罗·马拉，以及一个叫卡米尔·德穆兰的人混在一起，他是丹东的好朋友，我们稍后会提到。因为丹东是一个非常好的演说家，因为这是一个大块头，他是那种阿尔法男性，
he becomes a b-nock. Do you know what a b-nock is, Tom? Big name on campus. He's a big name on campus. Yeah, exactly. He found the Cordulier Club in 1790, Radical Club. talking shop, becomes its first president, captain of sports teams. Completely.
他成为了校园风云人物。你知道什么是校园风云人物吗，汤姆？校园里的名人。他是校园里的名人。是的，完全正确。他在1790年创立了科德利埃俱乐部，这是一个激进的俱乐部。谈话场所，成为其第一任主席，运动队队长。完全正确。
He's the big man, you know, everyone knows him on the campus, all of that. And as the revolution escalates, his star Carazon rising. So when in the late summer of 1792, there was the great storming of the Twiliery Palace by the kind of Saint-Coulot, by the intersectionally commune. D'Anton was very much at the forefront of that. When the Girondins were running France, they had him as their Minister of Justice. He wasn't really one of them, though.
他是大人物，你知道，校园里每个人都认识他，诸如此类。随着革命的升级，他的名声也随之上升。所以当1792年夏末，无套裤汉和公社对杜伊勒里宫进行了大举进攻时。丹东在其中处于最前沿。当吉伦特派统治法国时，他们让他担任司法部长。不过，他并不真正属于他们。
They always regarded him with a bit of suspicion. But, I mean, you mentioned the Churchillian aspect. He gives this incredible speech. You know, the Prussians are coming. France is at bay, and he says what we need is de loudasse, and encore de loudasse, and de judeau de l'Houderas. You know, courage, more courage, and yet more courage, and we will win the day.
他们总是对他怀有某种怀疑。但是，我的意思是，你提到了丘吉尔式的方面。他发表了那次令人难以置信的演讲。你知道，普鲁士人来了。法国处于困境，他说我们需要的是大胆，更多的大胆，永远大胆。你知道，勇气，更多的勇气，再多一点勇气，我们就会赢得胜利。
And, you know, it works. Now, behind all that, he's not just a great speaker. He's also actually good at running things. He's pragmatic. He's one of those politicians, very common. He talks a brilliant game and he's very flamboyant. But actually, you know, when the door's shut, he's very smart, he's very pragmatic. He takes decisions. He's ruthless, all of this. Over time, though, he falls out with the Girondale a bit. And so he moves closer to the Montagnar faction. So that's Robespierre, Marra. and co. And by, let's say, 1793, Dantan is seen as one of the three big beasts of that camp. So you got Marat, Robespierre, Dantant there, the three names that everyone knows. When Charlotte Corday wrote that manifesto about killing Mara, she mentioned Dantan and Ropespierre, didn't she did, exactly, she did. And he gets on fine with both of those guys. I mean, he's not a tremendous fan of, you know, Mara is not a great laugh, Dantan is a great laugh, and neither is Robert Pierre, but their relations are solid. There's no enmity between them. When Danton's wife dies in childbirth,
而且，你知道，它奏效了。现在，在那一切背后，他不仅是一位伟大的演说家。他实际上也很擅长管理事务。他很务实。他是那种非常常见的政客。他口才极好，而且非常浮夸。但实际上，你知道，当门关上时，他非常聪明，非常务实。他做出决定。他很无情，所有这些。然而，随着时间的推移，他与吉伦特派的关系有点疏远了。于是他向山岳派靠拢。也就是罗伯斯庇尔、马拉等人。到了1793年，丹东被视为该阵营的三大巨头之一。所以你有马拉、罗伯斯庇尔、丹东，每个人都知道这三个名字。当夏洛特·科黛写下那份关于刺杀马拉的宣言时，她提到了丹东和罗伯斯庇尔，不是吗？没错，她确实提到了。他和这两个人都相处得很好。我的意思是，他不是马拉的超级粉丝，马拉不是个有趣的人，丹东是个有趣的人，罗伯斯庇尔也不是，但他们的关系很稳固。他们之间没有敌意。当丹东的妻子死于难产时，
he comes back, he's been at the front and he digs up the coffin and embraces her in a very gothic manner. Ross Pierre writes him a very sweet letter. He does. Yeah. You know, he says, oh, I love you until death. You're great. You're my best friend. All of this. Nothing will ever come between us. No, I mean, you could say, on the one hand, that is very much the literary formula of the day that people do write like this. They write in an overwrought way that we would perhaps not do today. But genuinely, I think there's affection. There's a degree of affection between Dant-on-Rabers-Pierre. Well, I think it's important for the tragedy of what's going to happen to recognize the Robespierre does love D'Onton and indeed loves D'Amoulin as well. So there's no sense
他回来了，他一直在前线，他挖开了棺材，以一种非常哥特式的方式拥抱了她。罗伯斯庇尔给他写了一封非常甜蜜的信。他确实写了。是的。你知道，他说，哦，我爱你直到死亡。你很棒。你是我最好的朋友。所有这些。没有什么能把我们分开。不，我的意思是，你可以说，一方面，这非常符合当时人们写信的文学套路。他们以一种我们今天可能不会采用的夸张方式写作。但我真心认为，丹东和罗伯斯庇尔之间确实存在某种程度的感情。嗯，我认为对于即将发生的悲剧来说，认识到罗伯斯庇尔确实爱丹东，实际上也爱德穆兰，这一点很重要。所以没有任何迹象
whatsoever that they are heading for a kind of great crash at this point. So we're in 1793. And the beginning of 1793, I think it would be reasonable to call it a roller coaster for Dantan. So, as you say, in February, his wife dies. She dies in childbirth. He's been away. He's been a massive womanizer. And I think his grief for her is perhaps slightly colored by guilt that he hasn't been the best husband in the world. Just weeks later, April 1793, as we heard in a previous episode, Dantan is one of the first people appointed to the new Committee of Public Safety. And actually at first, he's seen as the dominant figure on that committee. The only thing is, at this point, spring, summer 1793,
表明他们此时正走向某种巨大的崩溃。所以我们现在是1793年。我认为称1793年初为丹东的过山车是合理的。所以，正如你所说，二月，他的妻子去世了。她死于难产。他一直不在家。他一直是个滥情的男人。我认为他对她的悲伤可能稍微带有一点愧疚感，因为他并不是世界上最好的丈夫。仅仅几周后，1793年4月，正如我们在前一集听到的那样，丹东是新成立的救国委员会的首批任命成员之一。实际上起初，他被视为该委员会的主导人物。唯一的问题是，在此时，1793年的春夏，
you know, we've talked before about how this is the beginning of the terror, the institutions being set up, the mood of paranoia, the obsession with conspiracies. Dantan is slightly losing touch with that mood, I think. He is too pragmatic. On the committee, he's sitting there and saying, well, you know, maybe we should look to make deals with some of our enemies. Could we detach the Prussians or the Austrians from the enemy coalition? could we talk to some of these
你知道，我们之前谈过这是恐怖统治的开始，制度正在建立，偏执的情绪，对阴谋的痴迷。我认为丹东有点与那种情绪脱节了。他太务实了。在委员会里，他坐在那里说，嗯，你知道，也许我们应该考虑与我们的一些敌人达成交易。我们能让普鲁士人或奥地利人脱离敌对联盟吗？我们能和这些
sort of provincial departments that are in revolt? We don't have to kill everybody. Let's find a way out of this. That's not what a lot of people want to hear. And he should have thought of that when he was busy setting all these institutions up. I mean, he clearly was not thinking through
正在反叛的省份谈谈吗？我们不必杀掉所有人。让我们找条出路。这不是很多人想听到的。而且他在忙着建立所有这些制度时就应该想到这一点。我的意思是，他显然没有考虑清楚
what could be done with them. No, he wasn't. I don't think he was. At the same time, there is, of course, this mood in the summer of 1793, this absolute fixation on virtue, on Republican virtue. you. And that's been there from the beginning, but it's become a lot more pronounced. And Danton's
可以用它们做什么。不，他没有。我不认为他考虑过。与此同时，当然，在1793年夏天，有一种绝对专注于美德、共和美德的情绪。这种情绪从一开始就存在，但变得更加明显了。而丹东的
financial corruption, which is not unique. There are a lot of deputies taking money. This is a fairly corrupt political system, but he is well known for it. Dantan has been taking bribes and he's been buying up land in his native Auxi with mysterious money. But the more that Robespierre becomes the B-nog. and he is the incorruptible. So the more Danton's corruptibility comes to seem a little bit out of fashion. Totally.
经济腐败，这并不独特。有很多代表在拿钱。这是一个相当腐败的政治体系，但他因此而闻名。丹东一直在收受贿赂，并用不明来源的钱在他家乡阿尔西购买土地。但罗伯斯庇尔越成为校园风云人物，而且他是“不可腐蚀者”。所以丹东的腐败性就显得有点过时了。完全正确。
His style is unfashionable. So June 1793, I mean, only a few months after his wife died, he marries again. And he marries a girl called Louise. I mean, she is a girl. She's 16 years old and she's been looking after the kids.
他的风格过时了。所以1793年6月，我的意思是，在他妻子去世仅仅几个月后，他又结婚了。他娶了一个叫路易丝的女孩。我的意思是，她确实是个女孩。她才16岁，一直在照顾他的孩子们。
And he takes her back to his hometown of RSI on a break. And while he's away, on the 10th of July, he is voted off the Committee of Public Safety by the Convention. Now, this doesn't necessarily have to be an immensely sinister thing. People are being rotated on and off the Committee of Public Safety fairly often. And he's not completely out of favour. So actually, in September, that people in the Convention say,
他带她回到了他的家乡阿尔西度假。在他离开期间，7月10日，他被国民公会投票踢出了救国委员会。现在，这不一定非得是一件极其险恶的事情。人们经常被轮换进出救国委员会。而且他并没有完全失宠。所以实际上在九月，国民公会的人说，
would you like to come back onto the committee? You know, the committee could use you. And he said, no, I don't really want to join any committee. I'd rather, I'll be a spur to them all. I mean, actually, that's a very Churchill thing to say. You can absolutely imagine Churchill doing that. I won't get involved, but I'll kind of be involved with all of them.
你想回到委员会吗？你知道，委员会可以用你。他说，不，我真的不想加入任何委员会。我宁愿成为他们所有人的鞭策者。我的意思是，实际上，这真是一句非常丘吉尔的话。你绝对可以想象丘吉尔会那样做。我不会参与其中，但我会以某种方式参与他们所有人。
So that's September. Middle October, 1793, Dantan falls ill. This is such a theme of the revolution. As we talked about before, these blokes are young. They're under enormous pressure.
所以那是九月。1793年10月中旬，丹东病倒了。这是革命的一个主题。正如我们之前谈到的，这些家伙很年轻。他们承受着巨大的压力。
They're drinking a lot. They are, I mean, imagine the stress. You know, your country is at war. There's rebellions. plus you could lose your head if you manage things badly. I mean, you talked about the big three. Mara famously is always returning to his bath because he breaks out in postules. Yeah.
他们喝了很多酒。他们是，我的意思是，想象一下那种压力。你知道，你的国家处于战争状态。有叛乱。加上如果你管理不善，你可能会丢掉脑袋。我的意思是，你谈到了三巨头。马拉以总是回到浴缸里而闻名，因为他身上长满了脓疱。是的。
And we said Harrods Pierre is always taking to bed with kind of nervous prostration. It's a theme. Completely. They're leading a very unhealthy existence. And by the time he comes back, so he comes back about six weeks later from our sea where he's been kind of convalescing. He comes back in mid-November and things have changed. So two big things have happened that you described in the last two episodes. Macrientoinette has been executed and the Girondin have been executed.
我们说过罗伯斯庇尔总是因为某种神经衰弱而卧床不起。这是一个主题。完全正确。他们过着非常不健康的生活。当他回来时，也就是大约六周后，他从他一直在康复的阿尔西回来。他在11月中旬回来，情况已经变了。所以你描述的最后两集里发生了两件大事。玛丽·安托瓦内特被处决了，吉伦特派也被处决了。
And by now, the reign of terror is well institutionalized and is well underway, which brings us to the big picture. So to remind people, the Montagnar have been running the roost since the summer and their power is embodied now in these two committees. So you have the Committee of Public Safety, which directs policy, and the Committee of General Security. which controls the police and the revolutionary tribunal. Now, there is a new constitution.
到目前为止，恐怖统治已经制度化并顺利进行，这把我们带到了大局。所以提醒一下大家，山岳派自夏天以来一直掌权，他们的权力现在体现在这两个委员会中。所以你有指导政策的救国委员会，以及控制警察和革命法庭的治安委员会。现在，有一部新宪法。
There is a new democratic constitution, but it has been placed on hold. Effectively, there is a state of emergency in France for completely understandable reasons. So Rob Spierre's kind of minimi, Louis-Ontoine de Saint-Just, the kind of archangel of death, archangel of terror. He has moved a resolution on the 10th of October to make the provisional government of France revolutionary until the peace. Basically, we're not going to implement the new constitution. The committee of public safety is going to run things until we have peace and only then will we do it. And Dominant, just to say, because people might think this is a cynical move. Yeah, I really don't
有一部新的民主宪法，但它已被搁置。实际上，由于完全可以理解的原因，法国处于紧急状态。所以罗伯斯庇尔的“小跟班”，路易-安托万·德·圣茹斯特，那种死亡天使，恐怖天使。他在10月10日提出了一项决议，使法国的临时政府在和平到来之前保持革命状态。基本上，我们不会实施新宪法。救国委员会将管理事务，直到我们实现和平，只有那时我们才会实施它。多米尼克，只是想说，因为人们可能认为这是一个愤世嫉俗的举动。是的，我真的不
think it is. Saint-Jouist, with Robespierre, had played a key role in writing up that constitution. And we're talking about this in the next episode. You know, they genuinely, and I think correctly see that this is not a time to be experimenting with new constitutions. Because France is in a state of crisis and maybe you can say it does need a firm hand. It's a complicated question actually and I mean we'll answer this to some extent in our very final episode, but I think a couple of things can be true at once. Number one, the institutions of terror, the committed public safety, do actually stabilize the situation. They do provide leadership and they do manage to, you know, they defeat the rebellions and they hold the line on the frontiers and indeed start to win the war. So to that extent, absolutely right. The only question is when you get to 1794, there is a definite question mark about whether, you know, Robespierre at that point, he will never be satisfied that France is a peace because there will always be corruption and vice to be fought.
认为它是。圣茹斯特与罗伯斯庇尔在起草那部宪法中发挥了关键作用。我们将在下一集中讨论这个问题。你知道，他们真诚地，而且我认为正确地认为，现在不是试验新宪法的时候。因为法国处于危机状态，也许你可以说它确实需要铁腕。这实际上是一个复杂的问题，我的意思是，我们将在最后一集中在某种程度上回答这个问题，但我认为有几件事可以同时成立。第一，恐怖制度，救国委员会，确实稳定了局势。他们确实提供了领导力，他们确实设法，你知道，他们击败了叛乱，守住了边境，确实开始赢得战争。所以在这个程度上，绝对正确。唯一的问题是当你进入1794年时，有一个明确的问号，关于，你知道，罗伯斯庇尔在那个时候，他永远不会满足于法国处于和平状态，因为总会有腐败和罪恶需要去斗争。
Just to say that this constitution is precious to Robespierre and Saint-Jouc, because they've drawn it up. Of course. I don't think it is a cynical move to entrench that dictatorial power, which is sometimes how it's presented. Yeah, they're not Vladimir Putin or something. No. You know, they're not cold, cynical, just interested in power for its own sake. Absolutely not. And of course, going hand in hand with the rule of the Committee of Public Safety is the policy of terror.
只是想说这部宪法对罗伯斯庇尔和圣茹斯特来说很珍贵，因为他们起草了它。当然。我不认为这是一个为了巩固独裁权力而采取的愤世嫉俗的举动，这有时是它的呈现方式。是的，他们不是弗拉基米尔·普京之类的人。不。你知道，他们不是冷酷、愤世嫉俗、只对权力本身感兴趣的人。绝对不是。当然，与救国委员会的统治齐头并进的是恐怖政策。
Let's just say, just equate that to going to revolutionary justice. So Sanjouc says very clearly on the 10th of October, between the people and their enemies, there can be nothing but the sword. We must govern by iron those who cannot be governed by justice. So violence is a part of their sort of strategy. This is not, though, a dictatorship. It's not controlled by any one person. And the committees are still reporting to the convention. There are aspects in which it anticipates later dictatorships. So power controlled by a very small group of people. Opposition is treated as treason and dissent is punished with kind of state-sanctioned violence. So in all those ways, it definitely looks ahead to the 20th century and lots of historians have written about this. But I think the biggest thing is that the state-sanctioned violence. So in all those ways, it definitely looks ahead to the 20th century and lots of historians have written about this. But I think the biggest thing is that the biggest thing is that actually what it's done is the French Revolution has been very anarchic for the last couple of years, very chaotic. And actually under this new regime, the Committee of
让我们说，把它等同于走向革命正义。所以圣茹斯特在10月10日非常清楚地说，在人民和他们的敌人之间，除了剑，别无他物。我们必须用铁腕统治那些不能被正义统治的人。所以暴力是他们某种战略的一部分。然而，这不是独裁统治。它不受任何一个人的控制。委员会仍然向国民公会报告。在某些方面，它预示了后来的独裁统治。所以权力由一小群人控制。反对派被视为叛国，异议则受到某种国家认可的暴力的惩罚。所以从所有这些方面来看，它确实展望了20世纪，许多历史学家都写过这一点。但我认为最重要的事情是国家认可的暴力。所以从所有这些方面来看，它确实展望了20世纪，许多历史学家都写过这一点。但我认为最重要的事情是，最重要的事情是，实际上它所做的是，法国大革命在过去几年里一直非常无政府，非常混乱。实际上在这个新政权下，救国委员会，
Public Safety, at about this point, autumn 1793, central state government in France is stronger than it has been for years, probably going back, you know, well into the reign of Louis XVIth, if not but further back. You know, you have a really high functioning machine now that is handing down ruthless, decisive edicts that is actually getting stuff done. The smack-affirmed government. Completely. Within it, however, there are lots of tensions. So just to look at the committed public safety, if you look about that, there are these
在大约这个时候，1793年秋天，法国的中央政府比多年来都要强大，可能要追溯到，你知道，路易十六统治时期，如果不是更早的话。你知道，你现在拥有一个非常高效的机器，它正在下达无情、果断的法令，实际上正在完成事情。强硬的政府。完全正确。然而，在它内部，有很多紧张关系。所以看看救国委员会，如果你看看那个，有这些
blokes, there's 12 of them, and they're meeting in a kind of green room. They're working very hard, late at night, all of this. And they're spending a lot of the time arguing on themselves. So on one wing, you have two people who've talked about it already. You have Saint-Just, and you have this bloke called Georges-old. Putin, who's in his wheelchair, the sex addict. Claims he was paralyzed by having too much sex. Yeah.
家伙，他们有12个人，他们在某种绿色房间里开会。他们工作非常努力，直到深夜，所有这些。他们花了很多时间在争论自己。所以在一翼，你有两个人我们已经谈过了。你有圣茹斯特，还有这个叫乔治·库东的家伙，他坐在轮椅上，是个性瘾者。声称他因为性生活过多而瘫痪。是的。
And you've got Rob Speer, who you've described already, pale, prim, glasses, wig, you know, all that. The incorruptible moral authority. Rob Spier, to be absolutely clear, it's really important, I think, that people dispel any sense of Robespere being a dictator. He is not a dictator. He has this great moral authority, but he's worn of a committee. and actually a lot of the decisions on the committee, and this will be really important when we're talking about the fall of Robespier, a lot of the decisions on the committee are made by these kind of military bureaucrats.
还有你已经描述过的罗伯斯庇尔，苍白、古板、戴眼镜、戴假发，你知道，所有这些。不可腐蚀的道德权威。罗伯斯庇尔，为了绝对清楚，我认为人们消除任何关于罗伯斯庇尔是独裁者的感觉真的很重要。他不是独裁者。他有这种伟大的道德权威，但他是一个委员会的成员。实际上委员会的许多决定，当我们谈论罗伯斯庇尔的倒台时，这一点将非常重要，委员会的许多决定是由这些某种军事官僚做出的。
So there's a guy called Lazarkano, who runs the army. There is Robert Lindy, who manages all the food supplies. These guys are like, their job is to win the war and to take all the decisions to manage the administration, to do all that. They're the people who are really keeping the show on the road. And when Rob Speer is talking at great length about the Republic of Virtue, these are men who are rolling their eyes and sort of surreptitiously signing requisition orders under the desk. Yeah. Military logistics is not Robespier's vibe at all.
所以有一个叫拉扎尔·卡诺的家伙，他负责军队。有罗伯特·兰代，他管理所有的食物供应。这些家伙就像，他们的工作是赢得战争，做出所有决定来管理行政，做所有这些。他们是真正让事情继续运转的人。当罗伯斯庇尔滔滔不绝地谈论美德共和国时，这些人正在翻白眼，并在桌子底下偷偷签署征用令。是的。军事后勤根本不是罗伯斯庇尔的风格。
Not at all. And the differences between these men and Robespier over time will become more and more pronounced, especially as they're working so hard. They're all knackered. They're all drunk, you know, all of this. However, the thing on which they're all united at this point is the policy of terror. So you described how they passed the thing called the law of suspects. The law of suspects allows them to arrest anybody. Yeah, that's basically it, isn't it, to arrest anybody.
一点也不。随着时间的推移，这些人与罗伯斯庇尔之间的分歧会变得越来越明显，尤其是因为他们工作得太辛苦了。他们都精疲力竭。他们都喝醉了，你知道，所有这些。然而，他们此时团结一致的事情是恐怖政策。所以你描述了他们是如何通过那个叫嫌疑人法的东西。嫌疑人法允许他们逮捕任何人。是的，基本上就是这样，不是吗，逮捕任何人。
Anybody, yeah. If basically your conduct associations, talks or writings identify you as an enemy of the people or an enemy of liberty, then you've committed a crime. So there's that. The Paris commune, I love this. The Paris commune has drawn up and published a list of characteristics that render people's suspect. These include speaking cryptically of the misfortunes of the revolution, spreading bad news, and this is the best one, affecting excessive severity in order to appear Republican. So in other
任何人，是的。如果基本上你的行为、交往、言论或著作表明你是人民的敌人或自由的敌人，那么你就犯了罪。所以有那个。巴黎公社，我喜欢这个。巴黎公社起草并公布了一份使人成为嫌疑人的特征清单。这些包括隐晦地谈论革命的不幸，传播坏消息，这是最好的一条，为了显得共和而表现出过度的严厉。所以换句话说，
words, if you seem too keen on the revolution, you're probably a traitor. And they say very specifically, the list of enemies of the people includes those who, while not having done anything against liberty also haven't done anything for it. So if you've literally done nothing at all, you're probably a traitor and an enemy of the people. If you're against the revolution, then you're guilty. And if you seem like you're in favour of the revolution, then you're guilty. And there's not really much leeway in between those two categories. No, it's a very hard balance to strike.
如果你看起来对革命太热心，你可能就是个叛徒。他们非常具体地说，人民敌人的名单包括那些虽然没有做任何反对自由的事情，但也什么都没为自由做的人。所以如果你真的什么都没做，你可能就是个叛徒和人民的敌人。如果你反对革命，那么你有罪。如果你看起来好像支持革命，那么你也有罪。在这两类之间并没有太多的回旋余地。不，这是一个非常难以把握的平衡。
And in his history of the revolution, the American historian, Jeremy Popkin, says, the great iron of this is a republic that is devoted to the rights of man. you know, the first, really the first state in history to be so explicitly devoted, even far more so than the American Republic, to this utopian greed, is running a prison system that is now on a scale without precedent in the Western world. So by the summer of 1794, by the time it's all over, about half a million people have been through the French prison system. Now, most of them do come out again. They obviously don't guillotine anything like a majority of these people. and even in Paris at the height of the terror, if you were accused of a capital offence, Tom,
在美国历史学家杰里米·波普金的革命史中，他说，这其中的伟大讽刺是一个致力于人权的共和国。你知道，历史上第一个真正如此明确地致力于这种乌托邦贪婪的国家，甚至远比美国共和国更致力于此，正在运行一个规模在西方世界前所未有的监狱系统。所以到1794年夏天，当这一切结束时，大约有五十万人通过了法国的监狱系统。现在，他们中的大多数人确实又出来了。他们显然没有把这些人中的大多数送上断头台。即使在恐怖统治最严重的巴黎，如果你被指控犯有死罪，汤姆，
for example, had you been too enthusiastic in your support of the revolution and outed yourself, therefore, as a traitor, the chances are that you'd still come out with your head on your shoulders. Unless I was an aristocrat. Yeah, that's true. Or Marie Antoinette.
例如，如果你对革命的支持太热情，从而暴露了自己，因此被视为叛徒，你很有可能仍然能保住你的脑袋。除非我是贵族。是的，那是真的。或者玛丽·安托瓦内特。
So the official death toll of the terror, I mean, estimates differ. Timothy Tackett gives us a figure. It says the official death toll is 17,000 people, which in the scale of the great story, slaughter as the 20th century is not great. If you include in that deaths in prison from starvation and disease, you're probably looking at 40,000. And then if you look at the Vande and so on, you're hundreds and hundreds of thousands. But, you know, it's not as enormous as the 20th century
所以恐怖统治的官方死亡人数，我的意思是，估计各不相同。蒂莫西·塔克特给了我们一个数字。他说官方死亡人数是17,000人，这在20世纪大屠杀的规模中并不算大。如果你把监狱中因饥饿和疾病死亡的人数包括在内，你可能看到的是40,000人。然后如果你看看旺代等等，那就是成千上万。但是，你知道，它并不像20世纪的
killings. Now, it's important to remember this is not senseless killing. It is killing with a purpose. I mean, that sounds a terrible thing to say, but they drew up the terror as this improvised response to the crises facing France in the summer of 1793. And basically, the terror does kind of do the trick. Yeah, it works. Yeah, they are back on their feet. So let's give you a couple of examples. The economy was in meltdown.
杀戮那样巨大。现在，重要的是要记住这不是毫无意义的杀戮。这是有目的的杀戮。我的意思是，这听起来是一件可怕的事情，但他们将恐怖设计为对1793年夏天法国面临的危机的一种即兴反应。基本上，恐怖确实起到了作用。是的，它奏效了。是的，他们又站稳了脚跟。所以让我们给你举几个例子。经济处于崩溃状态。
They have passed a thing called the Law of the General Maximum, which introduces the strict wage and price controls. And in the short time, it works. It props up the paper money, the Assignia. And Paris is still getting supplied with just enough food to keep going. that's fine. Obviously, they're winning the war. I mean, they've turned the tide in the war. So there are two big victories in the autumn against Britain and Austria at a place called Enchut and Vatigny. And then we talked a little bit about this last time. They've turned the
他们通过了一个叫全面限价法的东西，引入了严格的工资和价格控制。在短期内，它奏效了。它支撑了纸币，指券。巴黎仍然得到了足够的食物供应以维持下去。这很好。显然，他们正在赢得战争。我的意思是，他们扭转了战争的局势。所以秋天在恩舒特和瓦蒂尼这两个地方对英国和奥地利的两次大胜利。然后我们上次谈到了一点这个。他们扭转了
tide against the Federalist rebels and against the Vondayans. So they recaptured Lyon on the 9th of October and then a week later they won this big victory against the Vondayan rebels at Chorley. So at this point, let's say October. So this is about the point when Dantan is falling ill and going away. You might say, well, brilliant, the terror has worked. Why don't we ease off now? We don't need to arrest so many people. We can give the Sonson and the people working on the guillotine and have a few days off.
对联邦主义叛军和旺代人的局势。所以他们在10月9日收复了里昂，一周后他们在肖莱赢得了对旺代叛军的这场大胜利。所以此时，让我们说是十月。所以这大约是丹东病倒并离开的时候。你可能会说，太棒了，恐怖奏效了。我们为什么不现在放松一下呢？我们不需要逮捕那么多人。我们可以让桑松和在断头台上工作的人休息几天。
And actually, there are people saying that at this point. There are people who have the courage to say it. So there's a writer and deputy called Louis Sebastian Merci. And he said, I can't believe we're continuing with the terror. The Montagnan are men of blood and mud, stupid and ferocious beasts. So what happens to him? Of course, he's thrown into prison. Yeah, it's not reasonable to say such things.
实际上，此时确实有人在这么说。有些人有勇气说出来。所以有一位作家兼代表叫路易·塞巴斯蒂安·梅西耶。他说，我不敢相信我们还在继续恐怖统治。山岳派是血与泥的人，愚蠢而凶猛的野兽。那么他发生了什么？当然，他被投入了监狱。是的，说这样的话是不合理的。
It's counter-revolutionary, isn't it? And part of that is because Robespier and Sanjoust, I think in particular, have a vision of the terror that goes beyond just winning the war. They at this point see it as an essential tool to transform France into this virtuous, to an almost utopian republic. and they are doing what they see as positive things as well as just guillotining people now. So to give you a couple of examples, they are encouraging lots of local Jacaband clubs in the provinces. They're saying, you know, it's your job to go out there and to convert France, to start again, sing patriotic songs, have rallies, have readings, do all this stuff, educate the people.
这是反革命的，不是吗？部分原因是罗伯斯庇尔和圣茹斯特，我认为特别是他们，对恐怖有一种超越仅仅赢得战争的愿景。他们此时将其视为将法国转变为这种美德的、几乎是乌托邦共和国的重要工具。他们正在做他们认为积极的事情，而不仅仅是现在把人送上断头台。所以举几个例子，他们正在鼓励各省的许多地方雅各宾俱乐部。他们说，你知道，你们的工作是走出去，去改造法国，重新开始，唱爱国歌曲，举行集会，进行阅读，做所有这些事情，教育人民。
Well, don't forget, Rosfier had been to a Jesuit educational foundation. And the Jesuits are very keen on, you know, give me the child and I will give you the man. Exactly that. Education is a huge part of this, Tom. Yeah. Education, education, education, as another great revolutionary said. They have a plan for free education to the age of 13 and they have a new curriculum which will inculcate Republican virtues. They're very interested in a very 21st century way in language and in the names of things.
嗯，别忘了，罗伯斯庇尔曾去过耶稣会的教育基金会。耶稣会士非常热衷于，你知道，给我孩子，我就会给你一个男人。正是如此。教育是其中的重要组成部分，汤姆。是的。教育，教育，教育，正如另一位伟大的革命者所说。他们有一个13岁以下免费教育的计划，他们有一个新的课程，将灌输共和美德。他们以一种非常21世纪的方式对语言和事物的名称非常感兴趣。
So they want to rename whole towns, whole streets, parks and things after the virtues that they think. think the republic should celebrate. So in Orleans, for example, the different neighborhoods are renamed. They're called things like Liberté, Egalite, Brutus, Rousseau, and so on and so forth. I mean, that's something we're very familiar with today. Was it somewhere like Birmingham had a diversity street, you know, integration avenue, kindness, close, or whatever? Diversity Street, I think, was the name of a song sung by David Brent. Well, that says it all, doesn't it? The true air to the revolution.
所以他们想以他们认为共和国应该庆祝的美德来重新命名整个城镇、整条街道、公园等等。例如，在奥尔良，不同的社区被重新命名。它们被称为自由、平等、布鲁图斯、卢梭等等。我的意思是，这是我们今天非常熟悉的事情。是不是像伯明翰这样的地方有多样性街，你知道，融合大道，善良巷，或者其他什么？多样性街，我想是大卫·布伦特唱的一首歌的名字。嗯，这说明了一切，不是吗？革命的真正继承者。
A very disturbing thing, actually probably the worst thing they're doing is designing the metric system. Yeah, that's very bad, isn't it? So plans have been afoot for that for a little while. The convention is still working on it. The convention says the metric system is a symbol of the equality and a gauge of the fraternity that should unite all men. Because, of course, it's rooted in rationality rather than in organic tradition. tradition. Chaotic imperial madness. Exactly. And talking about language, they want to eliminate
一件非常令人不安的事情，实际上可能是他们正在做的最糟糕的事情是设计公制系统。是的，那很糟糕，不是吗？所以计划已经进行了一段时间了。国民公会仍在研究它。国民公会说公制系统是平等的象征，是应该团结所有人的博爱的尺度。因为，当然，它植根于理性而不是有机传统。混乱的帝国疯狂。完全正确。说到语言，他们想消除
the polite vu. So anyone who studied French at school will know there are two words for you, Tew and Vue. And they want to stop people saying Vue because it is old-fashioned and formal. Although one person who cannot stop himself is Maximilier-Robsbier, because he's so prim and formal, and he automatically keeps saying Vue when everyone else would be saying Tew. in the same way that he's wearing his colotte and his waistcoats. I mean, it's good to know that they want to make French more like English. Yeah, exactly. Get rid of the genders.
礼貌的“您”。所以任何在学校学过法语的人都知道有两个词表示“你”，Tew和Vue。他们想阻止人们说Vue，因为它过时且正式。虽然有一个人无法阻止自己，那就是马克西米连·罗伯斯庇尔，因为他太古板和正式了，当其他人都在说Tew时，他会自动一直说Vue。就像他穿着他的短裤和背心一样。我的意思是，很高兴知道他们想让法语更像英语。是的，完全正确。摆脱性别。
I think that would be the key thing. No, no need for it. So, there's a lot going on. And yet, there are some people who think it should go even further. And chief among them is a man we met last time. He is the editor of a newspaper called a Père Duchet. He is the scatological, pornographic, ultra-reau. populist Jacques Ebert, the scourge of Mariantoinette, a man who I'm guessing that most people
我认为那将是关键所在。不，不需要它。所以，发生了很多事情。然而，有些人认为它应该走得更远。其中最主要的是我们上次见过的一个人。他是报纸《杜歇老爹报》的编辑。他是那个粗俗的、色情的、极左的民粹主义者雅克·埃贝尔，玛丽·安托瓦内特的祸害，一个我猜大多数
who listened to our last episode will not have a positive view of this bloke. And Abert presents himself. He says, I am the champion of the working classes and of the streets. People are angry about high prices and food shortages, and the government should do something about it. They should be regulating the economy. They should be ensuring cheaper food. They should be having more surveillance to stop all the aristocrats who are clearly behind all this. People should be informing on their neighbours for hoarding food. And we should be executing merchants and shopkeepers who are not selling cheap food. It's blue sky.
听了我们上一集的人对这个家伙都不会有正面看法。埃贝尔展示了他自己。他说，我是工人阶级和街道的捍卫者。人们对高物价和食物短缺感到愤怒，政府应该对此做点什么。他们应该监管经济。他们应该确保更便宜的食物。他们应该进行更多的监视，以阻止所有显然是这一切幕后黑手的贵族。人们应该举报囤积食物的邻居。我们应该处决那些不卖廉价食物的商人和店主。这是蓝天。
Yeah. Yeah. A bear is really going for it. So there's that. He's really going for the shopkeepers. But he's all really going for the Catholic Church. We'll be talking more about the sort of religious side of the revolution in the next episode. But for now, just to simplify it, Abert and his allies, particularly in the sort of government
是的。是的。一只熊真的在全力以赴。所以就是这样。他真的在针对店主们。但他其实是在针对天主教会。我们将在下一集讨论革命中宗教方面的内容。但现在，为了简化起见，埃贝尔和他的盟友，特别是在巴黎政府，也就是公社里的人，非常热衷于这种去基督教化、反教权的议程。他们想把教堂变成理性神庙。他们希望神职人员通过放弃誓言、结婚、离开教会来展示他们的共和承诺。在1793年底，他们获得了相当大的动力。因此，在法国约6万名神职人员中，约有1.8万人，在埃贝尔及其党羽的压力下，放弃了他们的神职身份，
of Paris, the commune, are really keen on this de-Christianisation, anti-clerical agenda. They want to convert churches to temples of reason. They want priests to show their Republican commitment by abjuring their vows, getting married, giving up the church. And they get a fair bit of momentum towards the end of 1793. So of about 60,000 priests in France, some 18,000 of them, under pressure from Ebert and his cronies, abandoned their status as priests,
包括巴黎主教。嘿，多米尼克，对你来说是巴黎大主教。巴黎大主教。我不敢相信我竟然把他的职位搞错了。他在肖梅特和埃贝尔的鼓励下这样做，他们拜访了他，并说除非你明天这样做，否则你将被判处死刑，作为人民的敌人。而那种成为殉道者的想法在他身上并没有真正起作用。
including the Bishop of Paris. Hey, Dominic, the Archbishop of Paris to you. The Archbishop of Paris. I can't believe I've mis-bishoped him. He's encouraged to do this by Schomet and Ebert, who pay a visit to him. and say that unless you do it tomorrow, you will be sentenced to death as an enemy of the people. And the whole being a martyr thing doesn't really kick in with him.
他说，好吧，随便吧。他看了一眼他可能已经谈论了几十年的殉道者记录。他说，实际上权衡之下，我可能还是会放弃。是的。我其实本来就想结婚。讽刺的是，他最终还是被送上了断头台。哦，不。那太可怕了，因为他曾怂恿恐怖统治。
He goes, fine, whatever. He had a look at the record of martyrs that he presumably been speaking about for decades. He said, actually on balance, I probably will give it up. Yeah. I actually wanted to get married anyway. And the irony is he ends up being guillotined. Oh, no. That's terrible for having abetted the terror.
所以埃贝尔和他的同伙正在举行焚烧圣物、祭衣等物品的篝火晚会。最著名的是在11月10日的巴黎圣母院，他们举行了这场理性节。这是一种蓄意的亵渎神明的节日。所以，埃贝尔在祭坛的位置，
So they're holding bonfires of sacred. relics, investments and things, Abe and Co. And most famously in Notre Dame on the 10th of November, they hold this festival of reason. And it's a deliberately kind of sacrilegious festival. So, Ebert, in place
他称之为江湖骗子的舞台，他竖起了一个自由宝座，并找来一位非常年轻貌美的女子来扮演自由女神。非常年轻貌美，但显然牙齿不好。而且穿得有点少。穿得非常少。她栖息在整个去基督教化运动的一个主题上，那就是一个纸糊的
of the altar, which he calls a stage for charlatans, he puts up a throne of liberty, and he gets a very nubile young woman to come and play the goddess liberty. Very newbile, but apparently with bad teeth. And slightly scantily dressed. Very scantily dressed. And she's perched on what will be a bit of a theme of this whole de-Christianisation movement, which is a papia-mache
山，被放置在教堂中殿的中间，他们在上面放了一个希腊神庙，她坐在顶端。他们把她抬过街道，抬进国民公会，并把她安置在国民公会主席旁边，主席想必对此感到非常高兴。所以问题是，我的意思是，显然法国有很多虔诚的天主教徒，很多人非常认真地对待宗教，他们对此感到震惊。而这些人中的一个。我的意思是，他不一定是个虔诚的天主教徒，但他认为这是一件严肃的事情。那就是马克西米连·罗伯斯庇尔。他讨厌这个。罗伯斯庇尔是个自然神论者，不是吗？是的。他相信最高主宰。罗伯斯庇尔不是一个会开讽刺玩笑，或者说任何形式玩笑的人。不。
mountain, which is placed in the middle of the nave, and they put a Greek temple on it, and she sits on the top. They carry her through the streets, down there into the convention, and they install her in the convention next to the president of the convention, who presumably is delighted by this. So the thing is, I mean, obviously there are a lot of people in France who are good Catholics, and a lot of people who take religion quite seriously, and who are shocked by this. And one of these people. I mean, he's not necessarily good Catholic, but he thinks it's a serious business. And that's Maximiliel Robespierre. He hates it. Robespier is a daist, isn't he? Yeah. He believes in the supreme being. Robespier is not a man for a satirical joke, or indeed any form of joke. No.
他对这一切感到恐惧。我认为有两个层面，我认为作为一个相信神的人，但他也认为无谓地冒犯天主教徒是疯狂的。有什么意义呢？我想你是完全正确的。他认为这是错误的，但他认为这在政治上也是错误的。而罗伯斯庇尔，每当他看到有人犯错或做了一些他认为会破坏他们事业的事情时，他的自然反应，本能反应是说，好吧，埃贝尔为什么要那样做？埃贝尔是被人指使的吗？他为什么要做出那种会帮助我们敌人的事情？所以我想从这一点开始，他的脑子里就埋下了一些东西的种子。
And he is horrified by all this. I think in two levels, I think as a believer in the deity, but also he sees it as mad to needlessly offend Catholics. What's the point? I think you're absolutely right. He thinks it's wrong, but he thinks it's politically wrong as well. And Rob Speer, whenever he sees somebody make a mistake or do something that he thinks could undermine their cause, his natural reactions, instinctive reactions to say, well, why would Abe do that? Has Haybert been put up to this? Why would he do something that will help our enemies? So there's a seed of something in his head, I think, from this point.
总之，11月21日，也就是这之后几天，罗伯斯庇尔发表了演讲。他抨击了无神论运动，称其为夸张的狂热。事实上，多亏了他的鼓励，国民公会几周后投票支持并保护宗教信仰自由。换句话说，如果你是一个虔诚的天主教徒，别担心，继续吧。我们不会让埃贝尔把你扔进火堆里，所以我们。现在，最重要的是，在1793年12月初，国民公会通过了一项名为“霜月法令”的东西，重申了中央政府的权力。这是在
Anyway, 21st November, so just a few days after this, Robespierre gives a speech. He attacks the atheist campaign for what he calls its exaggerated zeal. And actually, thanks to his encouragement, the convention then votes a couple of weeks later to uphold and protect freedom of worship. In other words, if you are a good Catholic, don't worry, carry on. We won't let Abear throw you on the bonfire, so we're. Now, above all, at the beginning of December 1793, the convention passes a thing. called a law of Freemeyer, which reasserts the power of the central government. This is under
委员会的压力下进行的。委员会说，看，埃贝尔，激进分子，街上的人，所有这些。他们不应该指导革命。我们应该。国民公会投票决定，基本上国民公会和委员会将控制发生的事情。我们不会让其他人这样做。这真的很重要，因为革命的趋势基本上一直是非常无政府状态的，为了去中心化，把权力分出去。而现在他们正在回头，他们说，实际上，你们在这条路上走得太远了。我们需要一个适当高效的政府。
the pressure from the committees. The committees say, look, A-Beir, radicals, people on the streets, all of this. They should not be directing the revolution. We should. And the convention votes that basically the convention and the committees will control what happens. We are not going to let other people do this. And this is really important because the trend of the revolution has been so anarchic for basically decentralization, giving power away. And now they're turning back and they're saying, actually, you've gone far too far down this road. We need a proper efficient government.
然而，这并不意味着他们想拆除恐怖统治。他们想做的是将恐怖统治集中化，将其制度化为1794年政府的指导原则。它不会在1794年之前结束。这很清楚。它可能也不会在1794年结束。事实上，恐怖统治会结束吗？好吧，这就是丹东从
However, that doesn't mean they want to dismantle the terror. What they want to do is to centralize the terror, to institutionalize it as the guiding principle of government into 1794. It's not going to end before 794. That's clear. It probably isn't going to end in 1794. In fact, is the terror. ever going to end at all. Well, so this is the context for Dantan to return to Paris from the
乡下回到巴黎的背景，他在那里生病了。他在11月19日左右回来。所以那是埃贝尔反基督教运动的高峰，恐怖统治正如火如荼。稍微令人失望的是，我们很难知道丹东在想什么。不同寻常的是，与革命的其他大人物相比，关于丹东的资料非常少。但据我们所知，丹东厌倦了无休止的激进化。他认为恐怖统治可能应该开始减弱。他认为我们不能永远与所有这些敌人作战。必须与奥地利人和普鲁士人达成某种协议。归根结底，我们现在有了共和国。让我们享受它吧。让我们安定下来，拥有一些
countryside where he has been ill. And he comes back around the 19th of November. So that is the peak of Ebert's campaign against Christianity and the terror is in full swing. Slightly disappointingly disappointingly, it's quite hard for us to know what Dantan is thinking. Unusually, we have really few sources about Dantan compared with other big figures of the revolution. But as far as we can tell, Danton is tired of the relentless radicalization. He thinks the terror should probably start to be wound down. He thinks we can't wage war against all these enemies forever. Some sort of deal is going to have to be made with the Austrians and the Prussians. And ultimately, we've got our republic now. Let's enjoy it. Let's settle down and have some
稳定、明智的政府。吃顿大餐。是的。他变得有点“政治休息”了，不是吗？他变得有点像那种“明智的政府”。所以在接下来的几周里，他聚集了这个小小的支持者群体，他们被称为，把这个英语化，他们被称为“宽容派”。换句话说，他们是那些，你知道，同意他的人。我们应该冷静一点。人们应该“不愉快地同意”。不愉快地同意，没错。抱歉，应该“不同意”。等等。不。在“政治休息”节目上，他们“不愉快地同意”，不是吗？
stable, sensible government. Have a massive dinner. Yeah. He's becoming a little bit rest is politics, isn't he? He's becoming a little bit sort of sensible government. So in the next few weeks, he gathers this little group of supporters and they're called the, this anglicise it, they're called the indulgence. So in other words, they are people who, you know, agree with him. We should calm down a bit. People should agree disagreeably. Agree disagreeably, exactly. Sorry, should disagree. Yeah. Hold on. No. On the rest is politics. They agree disagreeably, don't they?
是的。而大多数与丹东交往的人，我的意思是，问题是他们在这个时候，因为他稍微有点不时髦，他们不是绝对的大牌顶尖人物。他们是稍微二流的人物。他被踢出了足球队。他在替补席上。是的，他确实是。而那些和他混在一起的人，是那些甚至进不了第一队的人。举个例子，有一个人我们会回来讲，他是一位前演员和诗人，名叫菲利普·法布尔·德·埃格朗丁。这个叫法布尔的家伙，他设计了新的革命历法。但丹东交往的那个真正有趣的人，其实是他的一个老朋友，是我们之前见过的人。回到那一年，我的意思是，大约17年前我们开始法国大革命的时候，他是一个年轻人，名叫卡米尔·德穆兰。如果听众还记得的话，就在巴士底狱陷落之前，有这样一个场景，这个年轻人，脸色苍白，长发，站在巴黎市中心的皇家宫殿里，
Yeah. And most of the people who associate with Dantantan, then, I mean, the thing is they're at this point, because he's slightly unfashionable, they are not the absolute big name top dogs. They're slightly second rank figures. He's been dropped from the football team. He's on the bench. Yeah, he has been. And the people who's hanging out with that the people who can't even get into the first team. So to give an example, there's somebody will come back to who's a former actor and poet called Philippe Fabre de Glantine. And this bloke Fabre, he designed the new revolutionary calendar. But the one really interesting person at Dantan associates with, an old friend of his actually, is someone we've met before. Back in the year, I mean, about 17 years ago when we started the French Revolution, he's a young man called Camille de Moulin. If listeners can remember, just before the fall of the Bastille, there was this scene of this young man, pale, long-haired, standing up in the Palais-Royal in the centre of Paris,
在咖啡馆的一张桌子上，劝说大家起来反抗路易十六。这是整个革命的伟大导火索之一。而这个家伙，卡米尔·德穆兰，他现在33岁了。但人们总是把他当作10岁左右的孩子对待，不是吗？他们确实是。他们完全把他幼稚化了。
on a table in a cafe, exhorting everybody to rise up against Louis the 16th. And this was one of the great triggers of the whole revolution. And this guy, Camille de Moulin, he's now 33 years old. But people always treat him like he's about 10, don't they? They do. They completely infantilise him.
他们不叫他德穆兰。他们总是叫他卡米尔，叫他的名字，因为他们认为他不成熟。罗伯斯庇尔和卡米尔曾一起上学。他们去过同一所路易大帝中学，德穆兰比罗伯斯庇尔小两岁，但他们是好朋友。他们读西塞罗，读塔西佗，读卢梭，所有这些。罗伯斯庇尔是德穆兰婚礼的证人。
They don't call him Desmoulin. They always call him Camille by his first name, because they see him as immature. Rob Spierre and Camille had been at school together. They had been to the same Lise Lue Leucon, De Moulin was two years younger than Robespierre, but they were great friends. They read Cicero, they read Tacitus, they read Rousseau, all of this. Rob Spier was a witness at De Moulin's wedding.
他娶了一位非常活泼、聪明的年轻女子，名叫露西尔，她也对革命投入了极大的热情。天哪，我希望她不会发生什么坏事。是的，我的意思是，我希望我没有介绍她，只是为了把她写死。德穆兰比他的朋友马克西米连要兴奋得多。他更感性。他成为了一名山岳派代表，但没有人给他一份像样的工作。正如你所说，他总是被视为有点……一位历史学家称他为“不成熟的轻量级人物”。所以，你知道，他不可靠。
He married a very sparky, clever young woman called Lucille, who also was very invested in the revolution. God, I hope nothing bad happens to her. Yeah, I mean, I hope I haven't introduced her, only to kill her off. De Moulin is much more excitable than his friend Maximilia. He is more sentimental. He becomes a Montagnar deputy, but no one ever gives him a proper job. And as you say, he's always seen as a bit of a one historian calls him an immature lightweight. So, you know, he's unreliable.
他有点孩子气，所有这些。卡米尔·德穆兰对转向恐怖统治感到震惊。据报道，他对吉伦特派的处决感到恐惧。后来有人声称，当死刑判决下达时，他曾惊恐地大喊。而当丹东回来时，德穆兰已经开始公开呼吁采取具体的宽大行动，例如，因为革命在某些方面有一种仇外心理，无论如何，恐怖统治也是如此。
He's a bit babyish, all of this. Camille de Moulin has been shocked by the turn towards the terror. and he was reportedly horrified by the execution of the Girondé. It was claimed later that he had cried out in horror when the death sentence was handed down. And by the time the Anton comes back, Daimoula has started to publicly call for particular acts of clemency, for example, because of a sort of xenophobia of the revolution in some ways, of the terror anyway.
他们正在打击外国公民，而德穆兰说，哦，这真的很不公平，你知道，放过他们吧。现在他是丹东的一个有用的盟友，原因有二。第一，因为德穆兰是罗伯斯庇尔的朋友，童年好友，所以有他在很有用。但也因为德穆兰，尽管他被认为不成熟，但他是一位非常有才华的记者。在丹东回来两周后，
They are clamping down on foreign citizens and Daimula says, oh, this is really unfair, you know, leave them alone. Now he's a useful ally to Dantan for two reasons. Number one, because D'emelan is friends with Rob Speer, childhood friends, so useful to have him. But also because D'emelat, for all his supposed immaturity, he is a very talented journalist. And two weeks after D'Onton's return,
而且几乎可以肯定是在丹东的鼓励和默许下，他创办了一份新报纸。它叫《老科德利埃报》。它有点回顾革命早期的日子。你知道，还记得我们充满理想主义的旧时光吗，在科德利埃俱乐部，在科德利埃区，所有这些。这份报纸的第一期在12月5日出版，是对埃贝尔及其派系的猛烈抨击。
and almost certainly with D'Onton's encouragement in connivance, he launches a new newspaper. It's called Le Vieux Cordilliers, the old Cordellier. and it's sort of looking back to the early days of the revolution. You know, remember the old days when we were full of idealism, you know, at the Cordillet club, in the Cordillet district, all of this. The first issue of this comes out on the 5th of December, and it's a blistering attack on Abert and his faction.
德穆兰说，你知道，埃贝尔拿公款来制作这份报纸，他用“停尸房”的语言填满了它。埃贝尔谈论他多么热爱革命，然而当我发表演讲时，你知道，海滩上鼓励人们向巴士底狱进军。埃贝尔是什么？他在综艺剧院收票，他确实是。他是个收票员。五天后的第二版，德穆兰抨击了无神论。他说，这场反基督教运动正在破坏革命。它在为外国人做工作。而这两期内容都经过了罗伯斯庇尔的阅读和批准。罗伯斯庇尔对此没意见，因为罗伯斯庇尔认为埃贝尔正在挨踢。
And D'Emolyne says, you know, Abert takes public money to produce this newspaper and he fills it with the language of the charnel house. A bear talks about how he loves the revolution, yet when I was giving speech, you know, beaches encouraging people to march on the Bastille. What was Abert? He was collecting tickets in the variety theatre, which he was. He was a ticket collector. The second edition five days later, Damon Olaude goes for Aetherism. He says, this campaign against Christianity is undermining the revolution. It's doing the foreigners work for them. And both of these issues have been read and approved by Robespier. Robespier is fine with them because Robespier thinks Abe's getting a kicking.
太棒了。你知道，罗伯斯庇尔，厌倦了埃贝尔。但接下来的两期，也就是12月15日和20日出版的，走得更远了。所以15日，也就是第三期，德穆兰刊登了一篇对恐怖统治的抨击，他把它伪装成一种来自塔西佗的虚假翻译。是的。所以基本上是罗马皇帝，你知道，用暴政换取了自由。他们把简单的眼神、悲伤、同情、叹息，甚至沉默都变成了罪行。所以就是这样。然后第四期是对政府的一个非常直接的挑战。
Brilliant. You know, Rosbya, sick of a bear. But then the next two issues, which come out on the 15th and the 20th of December, go much further. So the 15th, which is issue three, Damila prints an attack on the terror, and he disguises it as a sort of fake translation from Tacitus. Yeah. So it's basically Roman emperors, you know, swapped liberty for tyranny. they change simple glances, sadness, compassion, size, even silence into crimes. So there's that. And then issue number four is a really direct challenge to the government.
德穆兰说，我们已经忘记了这场革命原本的意义。它应该是关于幸福、理性、平等、正义的。他说，我们有两个委员会，公共安全委员会和一般安全委员会。我们应该有一个宽大处理委员会，因为我们有20万人被关在监狱里。我认为我们应该释放这些人中的许多。他们没有做错任何事。对他们好一点。是的。
Damien-Lin says, we have lost sight of what this revolution was meant to be about. It was meant to be about happiness, reason, equality, justice. He says, we've got two committees, public safety and general security. We should have a committee of clemency because we've got 200,000 people in prison. and I think we should let a lot of these people go. They've done nothing wrong. Be kind to them. Yeah.
他直接向他的老朋友罗伯斯庇尔喊话，他说，你想通过断头台除掉你所有的敌人。还有比这更愚蠢的事吗？这两期内容引起了绝对的轰动。所以政府特工向委员会报告说，它们正在售罄。人们在咖啡馆里大声朗读它们。人们为他们听到的内容鼓掌。为什么它们引起了如此强烈的共鸣？
And he addresses Robespier directly his old friend and he says, you want to remove all your enemies by means of the guillotine. Has there ever been such great folly? These two issues are an absolute sensation. So government agents reports the committees that they are selling out. People are reading them out in the cafes. People are applauding what they're hearing. And why have they struck such a chord?
为什么它们引起了如此强烈的共鸣，要追溯到巴黎以外的事情。显然，总有人不喜欢警察国家。所以有很多人不喜欢恐怖统治，从来都不喜欢。但我也认为，有特定的时间原因。首先，这些报纸出版时，正值法国刚刚取得了一场惊人的胜利。他们从英国人手中夺回了关键的海军基地土伦，这多亏了一位名叫拿破仑·波拿巴的年轻人。所以战争现在进行得相当顺利。
Why they've struck such a chord goes back to something outside Paris. Obviously, there are always people who don't like a police state. So there are lots of people who don't like the terror, never liked it. But also, there are, I think, specific reasons of timing. First of all, these issues come out at precisely the point when the French have just had an amazing victory. They have retaken the crucial naval base at Toulon from the British, not least, from the British. thanks not least to a young man called Napoleon Bonaparte. So the war is now going really quite well.
但与此同时，1793年圣诞节前后，以及1794年初，关于他们已经击败叛军的地方正在发生的报复行动的消息传到了巴黎。所以我们将在下一集听到更多关于这些的消息。但里昂，成千上万的人被大炮炸死，或被刺刀刺死，或被枪杀。南特，2000人被淹死，被强行淹死在被拖到卢瓦尔河里的船上，
But at the same time, news is reaching Paris around about Christmas, 1793, and then the early days of 1794, about the reprisals that are taking place where they've already defeated the rebels. So we'll be hearing more about these in the next episode. But Lyon, thousands of people blown up by cannons or bayoneted or shot. Nantes, 2,000 people drowned, forcibly drowned in boats that were towed out into the Loire
然后被蓄意沉没，当然还有旺代，所以在旺代，成千上万的人被处决，整个城镇被抹平，儿童、妇女被迫挖掘自己的乱葬坑，一名初级军官
and then deliberately sunk and then of course the Vande so in the Vondei thousands of people executed entire towns wiped out children, women forced to dig their own mass graves one junior officer
我的意思是，这段引文在革命的通史中重复了几次，我的意思是它真的让你印象深刻，一名初级军官写道：我们将使用钢铁和火焰，一手拿步枪，一手拿燃烧的火炬。男人和女人，他们都必须死，除了小孩子。但关于那件事最疯狂的是，他写信给了他的母亲。
I mean this quote repeated a couple of times in general history of the revolution I mean it really jumps out at you one junior officer wrote we will use steel and flames, a rifle in one hand, a burning torch in the other. Men and women, all of them must die except the small children. But the bonkers thing about that, he wrote it to his mother.
是的。那只是信，亲爱的妈妈，只是为了让你了解正在发生的事情。总之，即使在巴黎，也有很多人认为这实际上走得太远了。这太疯狂了。就像，我们不能杀光所有人。罗伯斯庇尔不是其中之一。罗伯斯庇尔不喜欢随意使用恐怖手段。不。
Yeah. That was just letter, dear mummy, just to fill you in on what's going on. Anyway, even in Paris, there are a lot of people who think this is actually going much too far. This is bonkers. Like, we can't kill everybody. Rob Spear is not one of them. Rob Spier doesn't like the arbitrary use of terror. No.
但罗伯斯庇尔确实相信恐怖是指导原则。他确实相信暴力必须与美德并存，否则美德就是无力的。它必须是美德的。是的，没错。但他并不赞成某些革命者所表现出的那种随机暴行，我想。没错。我们将拭目以待。他与那些他认为只是虐待狂的人闹翻了。
But Rob Spier does believe in terror as a guiding principle. He does believe that violence must go hand in hand with virtue because otherwise virtue is powerless. It must be virtuous. Yes, exactly. But he's not in favour of random atrocities to the degree that some of the revolutionaries are, I think. Exactly. We will see. He falls out with people who he thinks are just being sadists.
但罗伯斯庇尔认为，如果它是经过适当计划的。如果这些人是人民的敌人，当然他们必须走。是的。所以当德穆兰抨击恐怖统治时，罗伯斯庇尔认为，这只是德穆兰的愚蠢和幼稚，他不严肃。当丹东抨击恐怖统治时，罗伯斯庇尔认为，这是典型的丹东。他腐败。他太松懈了。他太世俗了。
But Rob Spier thinks if it's properly planned. And if these people are enemies, the people, sure they've got to go. Yeah. So when Damoulin is attacking the terror, Robsier thinks, well, this is just stupid and childish from Damila, he's not serious. When Dantan attacks the terror, Robespierre thinks, this is typical Dantan. He's corrupt. He's too lax. He's worldly.
同样，他不严肃对待保护我们所拥有的东西。所以在圣诞节那天，现在是国民公会的工作日，是他们新历法下的雪月第五天。罗伯斯庇尔站起来，在国民公会发表了一场大演讲，他说，你知道，我要解释我们革命政府的原则。罗伯斯庇尔说，我们正在为自由而战，对抗它的敌人，战争还没有结束。罗伯斯庇尔阐述了他关于后来被称为“外国阴谋”的理论。所以这当然是自革命开始以来一直在酝酿的事情。但奥地利说，你知道，我知道英国、奥地利和普鲁士在法国内部有一个秘密网络。他们在俱乐部里有特工。
Again, he's unserious about protecting what we've got. So on Christmas Day, which is now a working day for the convention, there's the fifth day of Niveos, as they call it, under their new calendar. Robespier gets up and he gives a big speech in the convention and he says, you know, I'm going to explain the principles of our revolutionary government. Robespier says, we are fighting for liberty against its enemies and the war's not over. Robespier sets out his theory of what becomes known as the foreign plot. So this is, of course, something that has been brewing since the beginning of the revolution. But Austria says, you know, I know that Britain, Austria and Prussia have a secret network inside France. They have agents in the clubs.
他们在各部委有特工。他们在这里，在国民公会中，在我正在交谈的人群中也有特工。有些人正在与英国人合作。他们对我们了如指掌。他们迎合我们的激情。他们试图左右我们的意见。他们把我们自己的决议转过来对付我们。而多米尼克，他们有他的兄弟奥古斯丁，去过。
They have agents in the ministries. They have agents here in the convention among the people I'm talking to. There are people who are working with the British. They know all about us. They caress our passions. They try to sway our opinions. They turn our own resolutions against us. And Dominic, they have his brother, Augusta, have been to do.
土伦。他曾是土伦现场的一种特工。所以他曾在那儿，亲眼目睹了土伦与英国人的合作。所以他对英国人有偏执。而人们在巴黎争论的事实本身，对罗伯斯庇尔来说就是证据。皮特的金子。没错，英国的金子。所以他说，你知道，我们在你们的委员会里，我们要忽视那些一方面说狂热和过度热心的人的声音吗？另一方面，那些软弱和温和的声音，我们要坚持我们的路线，做正确的事。国民公会传来了一阵热烈的掌声，罗伯斯庇尔松了一口气。然而，这并没有解决丹东和德穆兰的问题，因为他该拿他们怎么办？
Toulon. He'd been a kind of agent on the scene at Toulon. And so he had been there and seen for himself the collaboration in Toulon with the British. So he's paranoid about the British. And the very facts that people are arguing in Paris is for Opspier proof. Pitz gold. Exactly, British gold. So he says, you know, we in your committees, are we going to ignore the voices on the one side that are saying that are fanatical and overzealous. And on the other side, the voices have kind of weakness and moderation, we're going to stick to our course and do the right thing. And there's this great torrent of applause from the convention and Robespierre breathes a sigh of relief. However, this does not solve the issue of Dantantantin and D'emoulin, because what does he do about them?
他的朋友们。两周后，罗伯斯庇尔去了雅各宾俱乐部，雅各宾俱乐部的气氛非常狂热，因为当然他们也是雅各宾派。而罗伯斯庇尔实际上以一种相当和解的风格开始了会议。他说，看，我今晚要说的是，派系斗争够了。我再也看不到派系了。我只看到法国人。你知道，只有我们，法国人民对抗我们的敌人。
His friends. Two weeks later, Robespier goes to the Jacquemann Club, and it's a very fever on mood in the Jacqueline Club, because of course they are Chocomans too. And Robespier actually starts the meeting in quite a conciliatory style. He says, look, what I'm going to say to tonight is enough of the factions. I see no factions anymore. I see only Frenchmen. You know, there's just us, the French people against our enemies.
顺便说一句，这就是凯撒在第一次世界大战开始时所说的。我只看到德国人。多米尼克，有什么东西能把所有法国人团结在共同的事业中，让他们团结起来吗？我的意思是，你认为你在这一集中听到了关于溺水和枪击的一些糟糕的事情，但现在情况变得更糟了。我应该警告听众，如果你在开车，请靠边停车，因为罗伯斯庇尔要说一些非常、非常煽动性的东西。这是一个巨大的触发警告。
This is what the Kaiser said, by the way, at the beginning of the First World War. I see only Germans. Is there anything that would join all French people in the common cause, Dominic, that they could rally behind? I mean, you think you've heard some bad things in this episode with the Dres. drownings and the shootings, but now it gets worse. I should warn listeners, if you're driving, pull over, because Robsey is going to say something very, very incendiary. This is a massive trigger warning.
他说，对于今晚的辩论，我提议以下主题：英国政府的罪行和英国宪法的恶习。太可怕了。罗伯斯庇尔疯了。他真的让自己失望了。他罪有应得。所以他们即将开始这场疯狂的辩论，抨击英国人。
He says, for tonight's debate, I propose the following subject, The Crimes of the English Government and the Vices of the British Constitution. Monstrous. That's insane from Robespier. He's really let himself down. He deserves everything he gets. So they're about to embark on this demented debate, slacking off the British.
然后德穆兰出现了。他迟到了。当他进来时，有一些嘘声。你知道，一些强硬派在对德穆兰大喊大叫。你知道，我讨厌你的报纸。关于报纸的争论爆发了。有些人开始对罗伯斯庇尔大喊大叫，你知道，你要谴责这个吗？他是你的朋友。
And then DeMoulinand turns up. He turns up late. And as he makes his way in, there's a bit of heckling. You know, some of the hardliners are shouting at Daimilar. You know, I hate your newspaper. And there's an argument that breaks out about the newspaper. And some people start shouting at Robespierre, you know, are you going to condemn this? He's your friend.
而罗伯斯庇尔试图巧妙地处理这个问题，因为他仍然非常喜欢德穆兰。他说，我同意。卡米尔应该放弃他的政治异端。他的著作是危险的，给了我们的敌人希望。然后罗伯斯庇尔说，然而，我们应该区分个人和他的作品。我的意思是，这太居高临下了。
And Robespierre tries to play this cleverly because he is still very fond of deemler. And he says, I agree. Kami should renounce his political heresies. His writings are dangerous. have hope to our enemies. And then Rob Spears says, however, we should distinguish between the person and his works. I mean, this is so patronising.
卡米尔是一个轻率的孩子。他33岁，有良好的倾向，但他被坏同伴引入歧途了。而坏同伴是丹东，是吗？丹东和像那样的人。没错。所以不要把他从俱乐部开除。让我们在俱乐部成员面前烧掉他的报纸。
Cammy is a thoughtless child. He's 33, who has good inclinations, but he's been led astray by bad company. And the bad company is Dantor, is it? Dantan and people like that. Exactly. So let's not expel him from the club. Let's burn his newspaper in front of the members of the club.
令罗伯斯庇尔震惊的是，德穆兰没有接受这一点。这是罗伯斯庇尔打算给的礼物。德穆兰说，什么？烧掉报纸，你疯了吗？而德穆兰说，我用卢梭的话回答。焚烧不是答案。所以那是卢梭的一句名言。
So Rob Spears' horror, Damonelan does not take this. This is the gift of Robesprier intense. Damonelan's like, what? Burn the newspaper, are you mad? And Damien-Lan says, I reply in the words of Rousseau. Burning is not an answer. So that's a famous phrase from Rousseau.
而卢梭是罗伯斯庇尔伟大的英雄和政治指路明灯。想象一下，你知道，这对罗伯斯庇尔来说是多么具有挑衅性。一场巨大的争论爆发了。罗伯斯庇尔基本上向德穆兰发出了威胁。他说，你必须明白，卡米尔，如果你不是卡米尔，你不会被如此轻描淡写地对待。换句话说，小心你的头。事实上，在所有人中，跳出来试图说，来吧，算了吧，算了吧的人。
And Rousseau is Robespier's great hero and political lodestar. Imagine how, you know, how provocative that is for Robespier. This huge argument breaks out. Robespieres basically issues a threat to D'Mila. He says, you must learn Camille that if you were not Camille, you would not be treated so lightly. In other words, watch your head. And actually, of all people, the person who jumps in to try to say, come on, let's leave it. Let's leave it.
是丹东。所以丹东跳了出来，设法让它平静下来。但丹东不知道的是，罗伯斯庇尔现在掌握了一个可以摧毁他的秘密。因为在过去的几周里，线人一直在向罗伯斯庇尔和圣茹斯特提供关于这个破坏革命的外国阴谋的重磅揭露。而这些揭露对丹东来说将是致命的。天哪，这些揭露可能是什么？只有一个办法可以知道。休息后加入我们。伟大的游戏。英国与英国之间的战略斗争，以及
It's Donton. So Don'ton jumps in, managed to calm it down. But what Don'ton does not know is that Robespier is now in possession of a secret that could destroy him. Because in the last few weeks, informants have been coming to Robespier and. and Saint-Just, with bombshell revelations about this foreign conspiracy to undermine the revolution. And these are revelations that for Danton will be literally fatal. Blimey, what could these revelations be? Only one way to find out. Join us after the break. The great game. Strategic struggle between Britain and Britain and
和俄罗斯？我们评估一位首相。我们高度确信，那是俄罗斯。让俄罗斯人负责就是第三次世界大战。他们击落了一架载有350人的英国客机。克里姆林宫里的人在玩弄，亚历克斯。你得问问自己，你想玩还是不想玩？你是首相。
And Russia? We assess a Prime Minister. With high confidence, it was Russian. Holding the Russians accountable is World War III. They took down a British passenger jet containing 350 people. Man in the Kremlin is playing, Alex. Got to ask yourself, you want to play or not? You're the Prime Minister.
你什么都没做！我们需要了解政策背景。今天所有的相关背景都将构建为一个框架，并分发到作战命令或Fragow中。一个说要杀死俄罗斯总统的Fragor。是的。来自Goldhanger的新作。谁能做到这一点？
You've done nothing! We would need to understand the policy context. All the relevant context will be structured as a framework today. and disseminated into an operation order, or Fragow. A Fragor that says to kill the president of Russia. Yes. New from Goldhanger. Who is going to be able to pull this off?
你是我的士兵，对吧？汤姆·麦克达夫中士，达菲。一段独一无二的音频戏剧之旅。像达菲这样的人，是我们最宝贵的武器。被设计为一部技术严谨的地缘政治动作惊悚片。英国打出了最强的一张牌。他是最棒的。对抗它最强大的敌人。猎熊。
You're my soldier, are you? Sergeant Tom McDuff, Duffy. An audio drama journey like no other. Men like Duffy, they are our most valuable weapons. Devised as a technically rigorous, geopolitical action thriller. where Britain plays its strongest hand. He's the best. Against its strongest foe. Bear Hunt.
现在可以在你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎回到“历史的其余部分”。所以多米尼克，在第一部分结束时，你承诺了重磅揭露。这些重磅揭露是什么？好吧。所以1793年10月中旬的一天，丹东的朋友之一，
Available now, wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome back to the rest is history. So Dominic, at the end of part one, you were promising bombshell revelations. What are these bombshell revelations? Okay. So one day in the middle of October, 1793, one of Dantan's friends,
那个设计了新历法的家伙，菲利普·法布尔·德·埃格朗丁。他听起来像个坏蛋。是的，一个糟糕的名字。他要求见罗伯斯庇尔和圣茹斯特，他们见了他，他们和负责警察的委员会——一般安全委员会一起见了他。
the bloke who designed the new calendar, Philippe Fabre de Glantin. He sounds a wrong in. Yeah, a terrible name. He asked to see Robespierre and Saint-Just, and they met him, and they met him along with the Committee of General Security, the police committee.
法布尔对他们说，我有关于破坏革命的外国阴谋的耸人听闻的信息。他说，我发现了这个间谍和基本上金融家、投机者、西班牙人、比利时人、奥地利人、捷克人、普鲁士人的网络，有很多不同的名字。这是一个由非常阴暗的人物组成的巨大网络，
And Fabre said to them, I have sensational information about the foreign plot to undermine the revolution. He said, I have uncovered this network of spies and basically financiers, speculators, Spanish, Belgian, Austrian, Czech, Prussian, loads of different names. It's this big web of very shady characters,
而这些人中的许多人都在冒充革命的外国朋友。他们正被世界上最糟糕的人，英国人，威廉·皮特资助。他们渗透了我们的俱乐部。他们渗透了国民公会。他们甚至渗透了执政委员会。而正是这些人资助了派系，批评政府，例如，埃贝尔，和他那极端的激进运动，他们是这方面的先锋。
and a lot of these people are posing as foreign friends of the revolution. And they are being funded by the worst people in the world, the British, by William Pitt. They have infiltrated our clubs. They've infiltrated the convention. They have even infiltrated the ruling committees. And it is these people who are funding the factions, criticising the government, for example, Ebert, and his ultra-radical campaign, they are the spearhead of this.
罗伯斯庇尔和圣茹斯特听了这些，他们当然感到震惊，他们对此感到厌恶，但他们并不感到惊讶。因为，当然，他们一直相信有一个外国阴谋。这只是证实了他们所怀疑的一切。真的有外国阴谋吗？不。不，这就是疯狂的地方。这个叫法布尔的家伙编造了这一切。
And Rob Speer and St. Joust listened to this, and they are shocked, of course, they're poor by it, but they are not surprised. Because, of course, they've always believed there was a foreign plot. This is just confirming everything they had suspected. Is there really a foreign plot? No. No, this is the crazy thing. This bloke Fab has made all this up.
所以基本上，这不是一个绝对疯狂的故事。法布尔编造这个是为了掩盖他自己的腐败。所以法布尔一直在做的是，我们在前半部分提到过，有很多腐败。有很多钱在易手，贿赂和所有这些。法布尔和他的几个伙伴一直在从银行、人寿保险公司，尤其是从一家名为法国东印度公司的公司勒索和挪用巨额资金，
So basically, this isn't an absolutely bonkers story. Fab has made this up to hide his own corruption. So what Fab has been doing is, we mentioned in the first half, there's been a lot of corruption. There's a lot of money changing hands, bribes and all of this. Fabb and some of his pals have been extorting and embezzling vast sums of money from banks, from life insurance companies, and above all from a company called the French East India Company,
该公司正根据政府命令进行清算。法布尔一直在拿走所有这些钱，而法布尔担心埃贝尔会揭露他。所以他想的是，好吧，我会谴责埃贝尔是外国阴谋的工具。我会告诉罗伯斯庇尔他想相信的东西。我会在埃贝尔揭露我的腐败之前把他搞垮。因为那是关键，不是吗？他告诉罗伯斯庇尔他所知道的。
which is in the process of being wound up by government order. Fabra's been taking all this money, and Fabry's worried that Abert is going to expose him. So what he thought he'd do is he thought, well, I'll denounce Abert as a tool of a foreign conspiracy. I'll tell Robespierre what he wants to believe. I'll bring down Abert before he can expose my corruption. Because that's the key, isn't it? That he's telling Robespierre what he knows.
罗伯斯庇尔会完全想听。没错。现在，起初，罗伯斯庇尔等人并没有利用这些信息做任何事情。他们有点搁置了它。但显然人们在谈论，因为谣言开始传播。谣言在国民公会周围传播。有关于腐败的谈论。有关于外国银行家和挪用公款、阴谋和所有这些的谈论。
Robespier will want to hear completely. Exactly. Now, at first, Robespier and Coe don't do anything with this information. They sort of sit on it. But clearly people are talking because rumours start to spread. And the rumours spread around the convention. There's talk of corruption. There's talk of foreign bankers and embezzling and the plot and all this.
这时，另一位名叫弗朗索瓦·沙博的代表，他也担心因为完全不同的腐败而被揭露。所以他去见罗伯斯庇尔，带着另一个阴谋。他说，我有证据表明外国人和保皇党背后有一个挪用东印度公司资金的阴谋。明白了。我的意思是，如果你持有东印度公司的股票，听到这些传言，你就会把它们拿出来。你会的。所以那就是法布尔一直在挪用的公司。所以此时，罗伯斯庇尔从两个不同的人那里得到了关于基本上两个不同阴谋的信息。他们都是虚构的，但他们都是受到真实腐败的启发，
And at this, another deputy who's called Francois Chabot, he's also worried about being exposed for quite separate. corruption. So he goes to see Rob Spierre with a different conspiracy. He says, I have evidence that foreigners and royalists are behind a plot to embezzle money from the East India Company. Got it. I mean, if you had shares in the East India Company, you'd be getting them out with all this talk going around. You would. So that's the company that Fab has been embezzling from. So at this point, Rob Speer has information from two different people about basically two different plots. Both of them are kind of fictional, but both of them are inspired by real corruption,
由试图掩盖自己腐败的人引起的。而罗伯斯庇尔，当他坐下来审视这些阴谋时，他说，好吧，很明显这两个阴谋都是真实的。而且它们显然都是同一个阴谋的一部分。有一个巨大的外国金融家、腐败代表和东印度公司的蜘蛛网。而当罗伯斯庇尔坐下来思考时，他想，这解释了一切。这解释了埃贝尔和他对基督教教会的攻击。它解释了所有的派系斗争，我们一直收到的关于恐怖统治和国民公会的批评。所有这些都是由英国人资助的。那个该死的威廉·皮特是这一切的幕后黑手。而法布尔，记住他是丹东的朋友。而丹东是出了名的腐败。丹东极其腐败。
by people trying to cover up their own corruption. And Rob Speer, when he sits down and looks at these plots, he says, well, it's pretty obvious that both of these plots are real. And they're both part clearly of the same conspiracy. There's this massive spider's web of foreign financiers, corrupt deputies, and the East India Company. And as Robespier sits and thinks about it, he thinks, this explains everything. This explains Ebert and his attack on the Christian church. It explains all the faction fighting, the criticism that we've been getting about the terror and the convention. All of this is being funded by the British. That flipping William Pitts is behind the whole thing. And Fabb, remember his friends with Dantan. And Dantor is famously corrupt. Dantan is incredibly corrupt.
法布尔和丹东都在批评恐怖统治。所以此时，罗伯斯庇尔是否真的认为丹东是外国阴谋的一部分？我认为很难说，因为我们有一扇通往罗伯斯庇尔思想的窗户。但可以肯定的是，如果罗伯斯庇尔想那样想，他就能。他现在有弹药来做这件事了。还有所有关于丹东在夏天曾向玛丽·安托瓦内特和奥地利人示好的传言。所以这一切都是阴谋论漩涡的一部分……没错。
Both Fab and Dantan have been criticizing the terror. So at this point, does Rob Spierre, seriously think that Dantan is part of a foreign conspiracy. I think it's very hard to say because we have a window into Robespier's mind. But what is definitely true is that if Robespier wanted to think that, he could. He now has the ammunition to do it. There's also all that the chat of the fact that Dantan had been making over to his to Mary Antoinette and the Austrians in the summer. So this is all part of the swirl of... Right.
关于丹东的传言很多，不是吗？我想几个月来一直有传言说丹东不那么纯洁。他不那么专注。好吧，他不是不可腐蚀的。不，没错。所以，罗伯斯庇尔并没有急于行动。我想如果罗伯斯庇尔真的对丹东怀有仇恨，他会立刻利用这一点。
Conspiracy theory. There's a lot of chat about Dantan generally, isn't there? I think there's been, for months there has been taught that Dantan is not quite as pure. He's not as dedicated. Well, he's not incorruptible. No, exactly. So, Robespier doesn't rush into action. I think if Robespier had genuinely been burning with hatred for Dantan, he would have used this straightaway.
他没有。但他所做的是，他准备了基础。所以整个1794年1月，他们在雅各宾俱乐部发生了争吵，我们在休息前讲过。在接下来的几周里，他一直在与革命的执行者——负责警察和革命法庭的一般安全委员会交谈。而一般安全委员会里的很多人都讨厌丹东，因为他们很喜欢经营恐怖统治。其中一个家伙叫瓦迪耶。当他们谈论丹东时，瓦迪耶说，瓦迪耶说了这句非凡的话，我期待着剖开那条肥大的大菱鲆。
He doesn't. What he does, though, is he prepares the ground. So all through January in 1794, they've had this row at the Jacquemann Club, which we had before the break. In the next few weeks, he's talking to the enforcers of the Revolution, the Committee of General Security, who run the police and the Revolutionary Tribunal. And a lot of the people on the Committee of General Security hate Dantan, because they quite enjoy running the terror. And one of these guys is called Vadier. And Vadier says when they're talking about Dantant, Vadier says, has this extraordinary line, I'm looking forward to gutting that. fat turbot.
当这句话传到丹东耳中时，如果你原谅我的语言，这是丹东的语言，不是我的。他说，如果瓦迪耶碰我，我就吃掉他的大脑，拉在他的头骨里。这就像西塞罗。是的，这就像克里斯塔马政府的最后日子。
And when word of this reaches Dantan, if you forgive my language, it's Dantan's language, not mine. He says, if Vadier touches me, I will eat his brains and shit in his skull. It's just like Cicero. Yeah, it's like the dying days of the Kirstama government.
所以1月17日，在雅各宾俱乐部争吵后的10天，一般安全委员会采取了他们的第一次行动。他们逮捕了法布尔，逮捕了沙博。所以这些是两个线人。他们逮捕了丹东的其他几个朋友。现在，与此同时，丹东和罗伯斯庇尔之间的紧张关系几乎每天都在增长。丹东仍然在发表演讲说，你知道，我们不应该走极端。
So the 17th of January, to 10 days after the row at the Jacquemann, the Committee of General Security made their first move. They arrest Fabre and they arrest Shabo. So these are two inform. and there rest a few of Dantan's other friends. Now, meanwhile, the tension between Dantan and Robespierre is growing almost day by day. Dant is still giving speeches saying, you know, we should not go to extremes.
如果有的话，我们应该在自由方面犯错。而当他说到在自由方面犯错时，这似乎发送了一个编码信息，即他反对恐怖统治。然后有10天的停顿，这期间主要是关于现在海地圣多明各起义的争论，最终是废除奴隶制。一个巨大的、巨大的问题，巨大的交易。我们今天真的没有时间讨论它，我想我们得在单独的系列中讨论它。但在废除奴隶制的第二天，也就是2月5日，罗伯斯庇尔发表了另一场具有里程碑意义的演讲，显然是针对丹东的。这是一场精彩的演讲。
If anything, we should err on the side of liberty. And when he says about erring on the side of liberty, that seems to send a coded message that he's against the terror. There's then a sort of pause for 10 days, which is dominated by arguments about the revolt in what's now. Haiti in Saint-Doming and ultimately the abolition of slavery. A huge, huge issue, huge deal. We don't really have time for it. Today we'll have to do it in a separate series, I think. But the day after the abolition of slavery, which is the 5th of February, Robespierre gives another of these landmark speeches, clearly aimed at Danton. It's a banger of a speech, this.
如果说有什么的话，我们应该倾向于自由。当他说倾向于自由时，这似乎传达了一个暗号，即他反对恐怖。随后有大约10天的停顿，这段时间主要充斥着关于现在海地（圣多明各）起义的争论，最终导致了废除奴隶制。这是一个非常、非常重大的问题，非常重要。我们今天确实没有时间讨论它，我想我们得在以后的系列节目中专门来讲。但在废除奴隶制的第二天，也就是2月5日，罗伯斯庇尔发表了另一场具有里程碑意义的演讲，显然是针对丹东的。这真是一场精彩绝伦的演讲。
It's a big speech. What's the point of the revolution? What's the point of the terror? and he borrows from Cicero, of course, who they've all read. They're all obsessed with Cicero. And he paints this picture of this Republic of Virtue in which, you know, vices will become virtues and all of this. And he says, we want France to be the model to the nations, the terror of oppressors, the consolation of the oppressed, the ornament of the universe. That is our ambition. That is our aim. You know, a wonderful vision.
这是一场宏大的演讲。革命的意义何在？恐怖的意义何在？当然，他借鉴了西塞罗，他们所有人都读过西塞罗。他们都对西塞罗着迷。他描绘了这样一个美德共和国的图景，在其中，你知道，恶习将变成美德，诸如此类。他说，我们希望法国成为各国效仿的典范，成为压迫者的恐怖，成为被压迫者的慰藉，成为宇宙的装饰。这就是我们的抱负。这就是我们的目标。你知道，一个美妙的愿景。
but we cannot have that without the terror. Without terror, virtue is powerless. Terror is nothing but prompt, severe, inflexible justice. Famous, chilling words. Yeah. And he says, you know, the critics of the terror say the terror is falling on ordinary people, but it isn't. Because if you're a virtuous patriot and you're a citizen, you have nothing to fear. if you are against us, you have no rights because you cannot be a citizen.
但没有恐怖，我们就无法实现这一点。没有恐怖，美德就是无力的。恐怖不过是迅速、严厉、不妥协的正义。这是那句著名而令人不寒而栗的话。是的。他说，你知道，恐怖的批评者说恐怖正降临在普通人身上，但事实并非如此。因为如果你是一个有美德的爱国者，是一个公民，你就没什么可害怕的。如果你反对我们，你就没有任何权利，因为你不能成为公民。
You're putting yourself outside the Republic. So as long as you stay in the tent, the terror will never fall on you. You'd have anything to worry about. Now, as R. R. R. Palmer says in his great book 12, who ruled, the thing about this is basically it's kind of a recipe for permanent terror because Rob Spear is saying the terror will fall on you if you ever step outside the tent. But basically he's saying if you ever criticize or if you ever disagree, you are not a citizen. You are not a patriot.
你把自己置于共和国之外了。所以只要你待在帐篷里，恐怖就永远不会降临到你身上。你没什么可担心的。现在，正如R. R. R. 帕尔默在他那本伟大的书《十二人统治》中所说，这件事的本质是，它基本上是一种永久恐怖的配方，因为罗伯斯庇尔说，如果你踏出帐篷，恐怖就会降临到你身上。但基本上他是在说，如果你曾经批评或曾经不同意，你就不是公民。你不是爱国者。
You are not a Frenchman. And therefore, you know, there's only one way you're headed. And that's, you're getting on your tumbril. This is the kind of blueprint for the 20th century totalitarian states. But I guess to defend Robespierre, he doesn't know that. He is still negotiating the contour. of this kind of new dispensation, which is something very novel and potentially chilling, as you said. But I think you have to believe in Ross-Pierre's incorruptibility.
你不是法国人。因此，你知道，你只有一条路可走。那就是，你得坐上囚车。这是20世纪极权主义国家的蓝图。但我猜为了替罗伯斯庇尔辩护，他并不知道这一点。他仍在协商这种新体制的轮廓，这正如你所说，是非常新颖且可能令人不寒而栗的。但我认为你必须相信罗伯斯庇尔的廉洁。
He does think he's doing the right thing. But that's the chilling thing, though, isn't it, about Rosspere? He's totally sincere. Yeah. If he was here now, he would say, you don't understand. I am going to build a better world. I genuinely am interested in virtue, because virtue without terror is nothing. That's exactly what he thinks.
他确实认为自己在做正确的事。但这就是关于罗伯斯庇尔最令人不寒而栗的地方，不是吗？他是完全真诚的。是的。如果他现在在这里，他会说，你们不明白。我要建立一个更美好的世界。我确实对美德感兴趣，因为没有恐怖的美德什么也不是。他正是这么想的。
That is exactly what he thinks. It's telling, I think, people keep falling ill so often in this series. It's a sign of how overwrought Rob Speer is that he gives the speech and he immediately falls ill, overworked, stressed. He seems, I mean, everybody has it, but he does seem especially prone to burnout. And he retreats for almost a month to the DuPlai family's house,
他正是这么想的。我认为这很能说明问题，在这个系列中人们生病的频率太高了。这表明罗伯斯庇尔是多么过度劳累，他发表了演讲，然后立即病倒了，过度劳累，压力巨大。他似乎，我是说，每个人都有这种情况，但他似乎特别容易精疲力竭。他退隐到杜普莱一家住了一个月，
which is where he lodges, which you described before. Now, while he's away, the pressure carers on building, France is now mobilising meritorily on an unprecedented scale in European history. 700,000 men in uniform. The whole economy is basically being put to work to feed and supply the army. And that means that everything else is deteriorating. So on the 23rd of February, government agents report to the committees. The situation in Paris is really alarming.
也就是你之前描述的他寄宿的地方。现在，在他离开期间，压力持续增加，法国现在正以欧洲历史上前所未有的规模进行总动员。70万人在服役。整个经济基本上都在为军队提供食物和补给。这意味着其他一切都在恶化。因此，在2月23日，政府特工向委员会报告。巴黎的情况确实令人担忧。
There are shops that are completely empty. The butchers are all closed. People are fighting in the streets for food. And when merchants arrive in the city with supplies in the countryside, they're being attacked by mobs of women who are scrabbling to get all this bread or vegetables or whatever. So it's like 1789 all over again. It is like 1789 or over again. But the committee are very unsympathetic.
有些商店完全空了。屠夫们都关门了。人们在街上为食物打架。当商人们带着补给从乡下到达城市时，他们遭到了一群妇女的袭击，她们争抢着要得到这些面包或蔬菜或其他什么东西。所以这就像1789年重演一样。这确实就像1789年重演。但委员会非常冷漠。
So the committee actually say, well, if the public, you know, they're winging about no bread, they must cultivate Spartan virtues. George Couton says, what are they complaining about? All they need is a single scrap of me today. If I had the police power in my hands, I would make privation, the order of the day. Slogans for a happier France.
所以委员会实际上说，好吧，如果公众，你知道，他们在抱怨没有面包，他们必须培养斯巴达式的美德。乔治·库东说，他们在抱怨什么？他们今天只需要一小块肉。如果我手里有警察权力，我会把匮乏定为当天的秩序。这是为了一个更幸福的法国的口号。
Of course, the person who's benefiting from this is Abert on the ultra-radical wing. Because by early February, Abert has turned his rhetoric up to 11. He is running these absolutely ferocious editorials saying, you know, Tavern, keepers, butchers, grocers, farmers, get them all to the guillotine. If they can't provide for the people at Paris, we will, you know, punish them until they do. There are protests in the streets.
当然，从这一切中受益的人是处于极端激进派的埃贝尔。因为到2月初，埃贝尔已经把他的言论调到了最高级别。他发表了这些极其凶猛的社论，说，你知道，酒馆老板、屠夫、杂货商、农民，把他们都送上断头台。如果他们不能为巴黎人民提供补给，我们就会，你知道，惩罚他们直到他们做到为止。街头有抗议活动。
There's this sort of sense that we've had so often the revolution of momentum, of tension, of moving towards an inevitable showdown. And that moment seems to come on the 4th of March 1794. Abert goes to the Cordilliers Club, founded ironically by Dantan, and he says, You know, heads have got a roll. I've got a list here of 73 deputies. These are people who supported the Girondas. They've got to go. Damien's got to go.
有一种我们经常感受到的革命势头，一种紧张感，一种走向不可避免的摊牌的趋势。而那个时刻似乎在1794年3月4日到来了。埃贝尔去了科德利埃俱乐部，讽刺的是，这个俱乐部是由丹东创立的，他说，你知道，人头必须落地。我这里有一份73名代表的名单。这些人是支持吉伦特派的。他们必须走。德穆兰必须走。
There's a load of moderates and weaklings. They're traitors. They've got to go. And at the end of this meeting, they take a black veil and they put it over the framed picture of the Declaration of the Rights of Man. And they say, we are not going to withdraw it until the people have recovered their sacred rights. And everybody understands, this is the cue.
有一堆温和派和软弱的人。他们是叛徒。他们必须走。在这次会议结束时，他们拿出一块黑纱，盖在装裱好的《人权宣言》图片上。他们说，在人民收回他们神圣的权利之前，我们不会撤回它。每个人都明白，这就是信号。
the signal for a new insurrection, a new attack on the convention, effectively, a new son-coulot coup. But the difference between this and previous ones is that this one fizzles out almost immediately. Because they call to the sections of Paris, the neighbourhoods, but only one of them, the Cordilliers' home one, is the only one that answers the call. The Paris Commune, the city government doesn't call out the National Guard, there is a sense, I think, that Paris is exhausted. That basically people are sick of grabbing their halberds or whatever and, you know, taking to the streets. Is this the first time that an attempt to outflank the kind of establishment on the left fails?
这是新起义的信号，是对国民公会的新攻击，实际上，是一场新的无套裤汉政变。但这次与以往的不同之处在于，这次几乎立即就平息了。因为他们呼吁巴黎的各个区，各个街区，但只有其中一个，即科德利埃俱乐部所在的那一个，是唯一响应号召的。巴黎公社，城市政府没有召集国民自卫军，我认为有一种感觉，巴黎已经精疲力竭了。基本上人们已经厌倦了抓起他们的长戟或其他什么东西，你知道，走上街头。这是左翼体制外试图侧翼包抄的第一次失败吗？
Yes, it is. That radicalism up till now has always seemed to have the wind in its sails. And this is the first time that the wind doesn't blow the sails. Yes, it is. That's what Abe's fate. absolutely denotes. It's like this far and no further. The radical energies of the revolution have reached their kind of natural limit, I would say. So amid all this, amid all this kind of chaos, the convention votes to renew the powers of the Committee of Public Safety for another month.
是的，确实如此。到目前为止，激进主义似乎总是顺风顺水。而这是第一次风没有吹动帆。是的，确实如此。这就是埃贝尔的命运所明确表示的。这就像到此为止，不能再进一步了。我会说，革命的激进能量已经达到了它们的自然极限。因此，在这一切之中，在所有这种混乱之中，国民公会投票决定将救国委员会的权力再延长一个月。
And that same evening, Robespier returns from his sickbed for the first time in weeks. And he goes to the Committee of Public Safety. It's a momentous sort of late-night meeting. San Joust has brought along a big report on the rival factions, a denunciation of the factions. So I want to read this to the convention tomorrow. The rest of the committee say, fine, go for it. So the next day, the 13th of March, Sanjust gets up in the tribune of the convention, and he reads out what he calls, a report on the factions of foreign inspiration and on the conspiracy plotted by them to destroy representative government by corruption and to starve Paris.
就在那天晚上，罗伯斯庇尔几周来第一次从病床上回来。他去了救国委员会。这是一个重大的深夜会议。圣茹斯特带来了一份关于敌对派系的大报告，一份对这些派系的谴责。所以我想明天在国民公会上宣读这份报告。委员会的其他成员说，好，去做吧。所以第二天，3月13日，圣茹斯特在国民公会的讲坛上站起来，宣读了他所谓的“关于受外国煽动的派系以及他们密谋通过腐败和让巴黎挨饿来摧毁代议制政府的报告”。
And San Jose says to the convention, Sanjutor is a very compelling speaker. People are frightened of Sanjutor as a speaker because he's so good at it. He says all of this that we see on the streets right now, the food shortages, the political opposition, the sense of mounting chaos. This is part of a vast conspiracy masterminded from London, a conspiracy so vast that it's penetrated the clubs
圣茹斯特对国民公会说，圣茹斯特是一位非常有说服力的演讲者。人们害怕圣茹斯特作为演讲者，因为他太擅长了。他说，我们现在在街上看到的一切，食物短缺，政治反对派，日益增长的混乱感。这是伦敦策划的一场巨大阴谋的一部分，这场阴谋如此巨大，以至于它渗透到了俱乐部，
and it's working through the factions, people who are moderates, people who are extremists, they're all pretending, they are working for our enemies. Every faction is criminal because it works to divide our citizens. And as Palmer says in his book, it's not the voice of revolution.
并且正在通过派系运作，那些温和派，那些极端派，他们都在伪装，他们是在为我们的敌人工作。每一个派系都是犯罪的，因为它致力于分裂我们的公民。正如帕尔默在他的书中所说，这不是革命的声音。
It's not the voice of rebellion. This is the language of men in power. So it's the language of authority stamping out dissent. And that evening, the committee makes its move. Ebert and his key collaborators are arrested and taken off to prison. alongside, and this is a very reign of terror trick, this bizarre collection of people
这不是叛乱的声音。这是当权者的语言。所以这是权威镇压异议的语言。那天晚上，委员会采取了行动。埃贝尔和他的主要合作者被捕并被带走关进监狱。与此同时，这是一个非常恐怖统治的伎俩，这群奇怪的人，
that they will just throw in to try to give the appearance of a conspiracy. So to quote Palmer on this, the people arrested included a Dutch banker, a French general, a hairdresser, a bookseller, a tobacconist, a doctor, a surgeon's apprentice, an ex-peasant woman,
他们只是把他们扔进去，试图制造一种阴谋的假象。引用帕尔默的话，被捕的人包括一名荷兰银行家、一名法国将军、一名理发师、一名书商、一名烟草商、一名医生、一名外科医生学徒、一名曾经的农民妇女，
and someone described as a man of letters. String up the man of letters. Definitely. Someone described as a man of letters is a very nice touch. It's like in the old days, like in the old days of my mid-market newspaper, tub thumping, when I used to refer to people,
以及一个被描述为文人的人。把那个文人吊起来。当然。被描述为文人是一个非常好的点缀。就像过去的日子，就像我以前在中端市场报纸上大声疾呼的日子，当我提到我所不赞同的人时，
I disapproved of self-styled intellectuals. Anyway, these people are all dragged in front of the tribunal. They're accused of being a foreign conspiracy. The trial begins on the 22nd of March. A bear is accused of trying to undermine the economy, but there's a tax on shopkeepers. Abe can't believe this. Yeah.
我称他们为自封的知识分子。总之，这些人全都被拖到了法庭前。他们被指控为外国阴谋。审判于3月22日开始。埃贝尔被指控试图破坏经济，但这是对店主的攻击。埃贝尔简直不敢相信。是的。
He's the toast of the streets. He's a friend of the people. Yeah. Abeau is completely stunned by this. And he doesn't take it seriously, I think. He thinks the streets will rise and rescue him. And this doesn't happen at all. And when he's proclaimed guilty on the 24th of March and his sentence to death,
他是街头的宠儿。他是人民的朋友。是的。埃贝尔对此完全惊呆了。而且我认为他没有认真对待。他认为街头会起义并救他。但这根本没有发生。当他在3月24日被宣布有罪并被判处死刑时，
Abeau is stunned. He can't believe it. Don't you know who I am? Exactly. He's taken away. He's taken straight to the guillotine. There's a massive crowd. and people are so excited about this.
埃贝尔惊呆了。他简直不敢相信。你不知道我是谁吗？正是如此。他被带走了。他被直接带到了断头台。那里有大量的人群。人们对这件事感到非常兴奋。
I mean, A-Bear, the man who wanted to guillotine everybody else, he's getting killetons. And he disgraces himself. He's a shambles. He's no Marion Twinnett. So he does not behave with, yeah, the dignity of the ex-Queen. No. So one man in the crowd, the government agents reported to the committee is what was said.
我是说，埃贝尔，那个想把所有其他人都送上断头台的人，他自己却被送上了断头台。他丢尽了脸。他一团糟。他可不是玛丽·安托瓦内特。所以他的表现并没有，是的，前王后的尊严。没有。所以人群中的一个人，政府特工向委员会报告了所说的话。
So there's brilliant quotes. One man in the crowd apparently said of Abe and his collaborators, they died like cowards without balls. And another one sounding very Trumpy, And I have to say, said, we thought that A bear would have more courage, but he died like a loser. Thank you for your attention to this matter. Yeah, he died like a dog. Anyway, that's the end of ABA.
所以有精彩的引语。人群中的一个人显然谈到埃贝尔和他的合作者时说，他们死得像懦夫一样，没有胆量。另一个人听起来非常像特朗普，我不得不说，他说，我们以为埃贝尔会有更多的勇气，但他死得像个失败者。感谢您对此事的关注。是的，他死得像条狗。总之，这就是埃贝尔的结局。
Now, as you said, Tom, this is a very significant moment in the revolution, because it's the first time you've had authority versus the streets, and authority has definitively won. And there's a sense, I think, now, okay, it's clear that where the revolution is, you know, is not going to go. You know, it's not going to tip over into this sort of ultra-populism. However, the other implication of this, the committees wanted to hold what they saw as the line between the two factions. They've basically crushed one. What are they going to do about the other, which is Dantan and his allies?
现在，正如你所说的，汤姆，这是革命中一个非常重要的时刻，因为这是权威与街头的第一次较量，而权威已经决定性地获胜了。我认为现在有一种感觉，好吧，很清楚革命不会走向哪里。你知道，它不会倒向这种超民粹主义。然而，这带来的另一个影响是，委员会想要保持他们所认为的两个派系之间的界限。他们基本上粉碎了一个。他们要怎么处理另一个，也就是丹东和他的盟友呢？
So now we come back to the issue of Dantan and Robespierre. As you said at the beginning, it's seen as this kind of titanic duel between these two completely different personalities, struggle for the soul of the revolution, all of this, a struggle for power between two implacable antagonists. But that's really not right. Rob Spierre, I think, does not want to kill Dantan. That's why it takes so long to do it. And he genuinely, I think, hopes that Dantan will come round.
所以现在我们回到丹东和罗伯斯庇尔的问题。正如你在开头所说，这被视为这两种完全不同性格之间的一种泰坦式的决斗，为革命的灵魂而斗争，所有这些，两个不可调和的对手之间的权力斗争。但那真的不对。我认为罗伯斯庇尔不想杀丹东。这就是为什么花这么长时间才做到这一点。而且我认为他真诚地希望丹东能回心转意。
So if you've seen the film, in the film from the 1980s, this is very celebrated scene where Dantan and Robespier have a kind of reconciliation. dinner. Organised by Dantan in the film, which I think is not correct. And Dantan is like stuffing himself with oysters. He's like a man at the rest of his history as Christmas dinner. Wine, port, foie gras, you name it. It's all flower.
所以如果你看过那部电影，在20世纪80年代的电影中，有一个非常著名的场景，丹东和罗伯斯庇尔进行了一种和解晚餐。电影中是由丹东组织的，我认为这不正确。丹东就像在狼吞虎咽地吃牡蛎。他就像一个在历史余生中吃圣诞晚餐的人。葡萄酒、波特酒、鹅肝，应有尽有。全是花哨的东西。
Exactly. But Robert Sparrow is just sitting there, chilly, doesn't want to eat anything. Actually, in the written sources, most of them say that they had this meeting, Dantan was very emotional, and some of them say Dantan burst into tears. Those sources tend to come from the later 19th century. And I think what historians think is they probably, what probably happened was it might not have been a dinner. It might have been a dinner, we don't know.
正是如此。但罗伯斯庇尔只是坐在那里，冷冰冰的，什么都不想吃。实际上，在书面资料中，大多数都说他们进行了这次会面，丹东非常情绪化，有些人说丹东泪流满面。这些资料往往来自19世纪后期。我认为历史学家认为他们可能，可能发生的事情是，那可能不是晚餐。可能是一顿晚餐，我们不知道。
But they must have had one or more meetings in the last week in March. Robespierre saying to Dantan, could you give us your support? Could you back the committees? You know, surely we can find a way through this. And Dantantan not playing ball, saying, no, I don't agree with you. I think the terror has to end. I think, I mean, I remember that Rob Spier, the stories that Dantan cried, that Robespier saw this as a maligned tactic on the part of Dantan to make him feel bad.
但他们一定在3月的最后一周进行了一次或多次会面。罗伯斯庇尔对丹东说，你能给我们支持吗？你能支持委员会吗？你知道，我们肯定能找到解决办法。而丹东不配合，说，不，我不同意你。我认为恐怖必须结束。我是说，我记得罗伯斯庇尔，关于丹东哭泣的故事，罗伯斯庇尔认为这是丹东为了让他感到难过而采取的一种恶意策略。
Yeah, exactly. But they're so emotional. They're always crying, aren't they, the French revolutionary leaders? I mean, I don't think it's unreasonable by Dantan. Anyway, the truth is, the sources on this are so vague. It's impossible to know. What we do know is that by the end of March, Rob Spierreier has made up his mind that Dantan has to go. It is clear to Robespier, Dantéier,
是的，正是如此。但他们太情绪化了。他们总是哭，不是吗，法国革命领袖们？我是说，我不认为丹东这样做是不合理的。总之，事实是，关于这一点的资料太模糊了。不可能知道。我们所知道的是，到3月底，罗伯斯庇尔已经下定决心，丹东必须走。对罗伯斯庇尔来说很清楚，丹东，
Dantant is not going to abandon his campaign against the terror. And actually, D'Amoulin has prepared a new issue of the Vue d'Aulé and it's seen as so damning about the Committee of Public Safety that the printers are refusing to touch it. So, as Robespier sees it, I mean, people always tell the story from D'Anthor's perspective, completely understandably and not Robespier's, but just from Robespier's perspective. Robespier's perspective is D'Onton is going to destroy the revolution. The terror is what's keeping the revolution going and Dantan is going to destroy it
丹东不会放弃他反对恐怖的运动。实际上，德穆兰准备了新一期的《老科德利埃报》，它被认为对救国委员会的批评如此严厉，以至于印刷商拒绝触碰它。所以，正如罗伯斯庇尔所见，我是说，人们总是从丹东的角度讲述这个故事，完全可以理解，而不是从罗伯斯庇尔的角度。罗伯斯庇尔的角度是丹东要摧毁革命。恐怖是维持革命继续进行的东西，而丹东要摧毁它，
and he's surrounded himself with a load of kind of total mediocrities and actors. Plus, he's massively corrupt and he's always taking bungs. Yeah. And you can't have that in a virtuous republic. No.
而且他身边围了一堆完全平庸的人和演员。另外，他极其腐败，总是收受贿赂。是的。而在一个有美德的共和国里，你不能有那种事。没有。
So the last days of March, Robespier and Saint-Jus to prepare the indictment. The case, as we've said, writes itself, right, the corruption. We know that Dantan took dodgy money. Robespier has all these allegations of massive conspiracies and things. And, you know, Dantan has been unguarded and he has said things to Robespierre that most people would laugh off, but Robespierre, you know, he's not a funster.
所以3月的最后几天，罗伯斯庇尔和圣茹斯特准备起诉书。正如我们所说，案件本身就写好了，对吧，腐败。我们知道丹东拿了不正当的钱。罗伯斯庇尔有所有这些关于大规模阴谋之类的指控。而且，你知道，丹东一直毫无防备，他对罗伯斯庇尔说了一些大多数人会一笑置之的话，但罗伯斯庇尔，你知道，他不是个爱开玩笑的人。
So when Dantan said to him, they were talking about virtue, and Dantan said to Robespierre, I know no virtue greater than that which I practice every night with my wife. Yeah. Robespier does not smile at this. He thinks this is disgraceful. And Saint-Ju thinks it's disgraceful as well. and in the speech that he will give against Dantan, he cites that specifically and clearly does not take it as a joke in the slightest. And I think the lesson is it's dangerous to make jokes when Rosfiel and San Jusseuzeuze are on the scene. Completely. So late on the evening of the 29th of March, the drama is set in train.
所以当丹东对他说，他们当时在谈论美德，丹东对罗伯斯庇尔说，我不知道有什么美德比我每晚与妻子实践的美德更伟大。是的。罗伯斯庇尔对此没有微笑。他认为这是可耻的。圣茹斯特也认为这是可耻的。在他将要发表的反对丹东的演讲中，他特别引用了这一点，显然一点也没有把它当作玩笑。我认为教训是，当罗伯斯庇尔和圣茹斯特在场时，开玩笑是很危险的。完全是这样。所以3月29日深夜，戏剧拉开了序幕。
So there's a joint meeting of the Committee of Public Safety and the Committee of General Security. Sanjoust presents them with his indictment. He says, I'm going to read this in the convention tomorrow. and then I'm going to call for Dantan's arrest. And the men from the General Security Committee, basically the political police, Vardier and Amar, they say, are you mad?
所以救国委员会和治安委员会举行了联席会议。圣茹斯特向他们提交了他的起诉书。他说，我明天要在国民公会上宣读这个。然后我要呼吁逮捕丹东。而来自治安委员会的人，基本上是政治警察，瓦迪耶和阿马尔，他们说，你疯了吗？
Dantan is a brilliant speaker. If you read this out in the convention, Dantan will reply, he will destroy you, and then you'll look like a fool. You arrest him first, get him safely locked up, then denounce him. Saint-Just is very offended by this,
丹东是一位出色的演讲者。如果你在国民公会上读这个，丹东会反驳，他会摧毁你，然后你看起来就像个傻瓜。你先逮捕他，把他安全关起来，然后再谴责他。圣茹斯特对此感到非常冒犯，
by the thought that they don't rate his rhetorical ability, compare with Dantons. He basically has a strop. He throws his hat in the fire and then storms out. That is a strob. Yeah, it's a massive sulk. So he storms out. And actually, all the other members of the Committee of Public Safety say,
因为他们不看重他的修辞能力，与丹东相比。他基本上发脾气了。他把帽子扔进火里，然后冲了出去。那是一次发脾气。是的，这是一个巨大的生闷气。所以他冲了出去。实际上，救国委员会的所有其他成员都说，
say, do you know what, you're right? We probably should arrest him first. So they agreed they'll do that. They drew up the warrant. One by one, they sign it. You can see this in the film, very famous scene. One member of the Committee of General Security says he won't sign it. And also a member of the Committee of Public Safety, Robert Lindy,
说，你知道吗，你是对的？我们可能应该先逮捕他。所以他们同意他们会这样做。他们起草了逮捕令。他们一个接一个地签署。你可以在电影中看到这一点，非常著名的场景。治安委员会的一名成员说他不会签署。还有救国委员会的一名成员，罗伯特·兰代，
who's in charge of supplying the army. And Lindy says, my job is to provide for our citizens not to execute our patriots. And that little hint there of a fracture within the Committee of Public Safety between the people who are getting stuff done, Lindy, Kano and people like that,
他负责供应军队。兰代说，我的工作是为我们的公民提供补给，而不是处决我们的爱国者。救国委员会内部那些正在完成工作的人，兰代、卡诺之类的人，
and then the people who love talking about virtue and organizing executions, that's going to become more pronounced in a couple of months. Anyway, this meeting breaks up. So it's now the early hours the 30th of March. I think it's pretty clear that in the next few hours, rumours spread and somebody tipped d'Anne and de Malin off.
以及那些喜欢谈论美德和组织处决的人之间的一点裂痕，在几个月后会变得更加明显。总之，这次会议解散了。所以现在是3月30日的凌晨。我认为很清楚，在接下来的几个小时里，谣言传播开来，有人给丹东和德穆兰通风报信。
There were various accounts of what was said. Dantant supposedly, one version said that he was told flee the city, and he said, no, they won't move against me, they wouldn't dare. D'Onton was cocky. Another version he's told to emigrate, and he said, no, I will never leave France. You cannot carry your homeland on the soles of your shoes, a nice line.
关于所说的话有各种各样的说法。丹东据称，一个版本说有人告诉他逃离城市，他说，不，他们不会对我采取行动，他们不敢。丹东很自负。另一个版本是他被告知移民，他说，不，我永远不会离开法国。你不能把祖国带在鞋底上，这句台词很好。
and there are stories that de Milan went to see his old classmate, Maximilian Rospier, went to his house but was turned away from the door and said, I am lost. If he won't see me, I am lost. Anyway, that night, the 30th, they are arrested, they're taken to the Luxembourg prison, they're going to face trial by the Revolutionary Tribunal. We don't have any accounts of the scene when they were arrested, unfortunately. But we do know that the next day, the 31st, the news spread very much. quickly. It was a massive sensation. A police agent reported, people are stunned and don't know what to think. And in the convention, a scene of total chaos. So one of Dantons' allies
还有故事说德穆兰去见了他的老同学马克西米连·罗伯斯庇尔，去了他的家但被拒之门外，说，我完了。如果他不肯见我，我就完了。总之，那天晚上，30日，他们被捕了，被带到了卢森堡监狱，他们将面临革命法庭的审判。不幸的是，我们没有任何关于他们被捕时场景的记录。但我们确实知道，第二天，31日，消息传播得非常快。这是一个巨大的轰动。一名警察特工报告说，人们惊呆了，不知道该想什么。而在国民公会，场面一片混乱。所以丹东的一名盟友
rushes into the convention. He says, unbelievable. Dantan's been arrested. Citizens, I declare that Dantons is as pure as I am. That's an unwise thing to say. Yeah, I know. God. I mean, else for trouble, why don't you? Risky. So there's Tumel in the hall. This guy who broke the news, he's called Lejeant. he says, they should bring in the prisoners, bring in Dantan Damiena, let them face their accusers, bring in the committee, let's have this out. And Rob Spier forces his way through the shouting throng of people. He is described as pale with anger and seemingly impelled by the sense of a great danger.
冲进国民公会。他说，难以置信。丹东被捕了。公民们，我声明丹东和我一样纯洁。那是一件不明智的事情。是的，我知道。天哪。我是说，否则会有麻烦，你为什么不呢？冒险。所以大厅里有德穆兰。这个传达消息的人，他叫勒让德尔。他说，他们应该带进囚犯，带进丹东和德穆兰，让他们面对他们的指控者，带进委员会，让我们把这件事说清楚。罗伯斯庇尔强行穿过大喊大叫的人群。他被描述为脸色苍白，充满愤怒，似乎被一种巨大危险的感觉所驱使。
And he gets up there and he says to the convention, from his perspective, not unreasonably, we've arrested so many people. Why does Dantan get special treatment? You know, we should treat the people we arrest equally. And he says to them, do you not have the courage to break a false idol? And then he is followed onto the tribunal by Saint-Just. The archangel of death, icy kind of recital of the charges. Danton was working with the foreign plot.
他走到那里，对国民公会说，从他的角度来看，并非不合理，我们逮捕了这么多人。为什么丹东得到特殊待遇？你知道，我们应该平等对待我们逮捕的人。他对他们说，你们没有勇气打破一个虚假的偶像吗？然后他被圣茹斯特跟在后面上了法庭。死亡天使，冷冰冰地宣读指控。丹东在与外国阴谋合作。
Dantan was taking money. And if you doubt it, look what's happening to France. Look at the shortages. Look at the collapse of that currency. Look at the hoarding of goods. Look at the unrest in the provinces. This is all the foreign plot. the men we are denouncing were never patriots.
丹东在拿钱。如果你怀疑这一点，看看法国正在发生什么。看看短缺。看看货币的崩溃。看看货物的囤积。看看各省的动乱。这都是外国阴谋。我们谴责的人从来都不是爱国者。
They were aristocrats more adroit and cunning than those at Koblenz, i.e. the emigres. Yeah, their maxims were those of Cataline. Exactly. So they've gone from being Cicero, they've become Cataline. So this does the trick. The Robs-Piers-S-S-Just combo, which often works, the convention fall into line. And so it is that two days later, on the 2nd of April, Dantant and Desmilae are led into the Pallé de Justice for trial by the tribunal. And as with Ebert, the committee have mudded the waters by throwing in a load of random people,
他们是比科布伦茨（即流亡者）那些人更精明、更狡猾的贵族。是的，他们的格言是卡提林的格言。正是如此。所以他们从西塞罗变成了卡提林。所以这招奏效了。罗伯斯庇尔和圣茹斯特的组合，通常很有效，国民公会排成一列。于是，两天后，4月2日，丹东和德穆兰被带进司法宫接受法庭审判。和埃贝尔一样，委员会通过扔进一堆随机的人来搅浑水，
bankers and things. There's a Dutchman, the Belgian, there's two Moravians, there's a Dane and there's a Spaniard. I mean, to be fair, everyone hates a foreign banker. They do, exactly. I thought you were going to say everyone hates a Dutchman. No, I love a Dutchman. You love the Dutch. And Fabre and Chabot, they're also there. So the two blocs had gone to Robespier to save themselves with their plot stories. Yeah. They failed to do so. And the point, of course, is throwing so many people in this to create the sense of conspiracy. And from the start, Dantan's in great form.
银行家之类的。有一个荷兰人，比利时人，有两个摩拉维亚人，一个丹麦人和一个西班牙人。我是说，公平地说，每个人都讨厌外国银行家。他们确实，正是如此。我以为你会说每个人都讨厌荷兰人。不，我喜欢荷兰人。你喜欢荷兰人。法布尔和沙博也在那里。所以这两个集团都去找罗伯斯庇尔用他们的阴谋故事来拯救自己。是的。他们没能做到。当然，重点是扔进这么多人是为了制造阴谋感。从一开始，丹东的状态就很好。
He says to his fellow prisoners, provided they let us speak at length, I am sure of routing my accusers. I don't think he thinks he's going to get away. He thinks he's just going to humiliate them and they will execute him, but he will go down fighting and history will reward him. He'll leave a name to posterity. Completely. At this point, I think, I do have to say,
他对他的狱友说，只要他们让我们详细发言，我就有把握击败我的指控者。我不认为他认为他能逃脱。他认为他只是要羞辱他们，他们会处决他，但他会战斗到底，历史会奖励他。他会给后代留下一个名字。完全是这样。在这一点上，我认为，我确实不得不说，
Dantan is very confused in my mind with Winston Churchill because I think this is exactly how Churchill would have behaved. You know, the sort of the bumpuousness, the arrogance. Looking to history as his judge. Completely. Yeah. I mean, this is so Churchillian. They ask him, the trial, yeah, when he's sort of checking into the prison or something,
丹东在我的脑海中与温斯顿·丘吉尔非常混淆，因为我认为这正是丘吉尔会表现出的样子。你知道，那种傲慢，那种狂妄。把历史作为他的法官。完全是这样。是的。我是说，这太丘吉尔了。他们问他，审判，是的，当他办理入狱手续时，
what's your name and address? And he says, I will soon be living nowhere. As for my name, you'll find it in the pantheon of history. I mean, that's amazing. Yeah. But de Moulat is even less modern. is, isn't he? Yes, he is. I mean, Damon, to be fair, who's often described as this sort of immature weakling. They ask him for his age, and he says, I'm 33, the same age as the
你叫什么名字，住址在哪里？他说，我很快就会无处可住。至于我的名字，你会在历史的万神殿中找到它。我是说，那太棒了。是的。但德穆兰更不现代，不是吗？是的，他是。我是说，德穆兰，公平地说，他经常被描述为这种不成熟的软弱者。他们问他的年龄，他说，我33岁，和那个
Soncoulot Jesus Christ when he stood before Pontius Pilots. I mean, you can see how, basically, if you were standing next to Donsoe, you'd be, you'd raise your game, wouldn't you? You'd raise your repartee game. And actually what follows, the trial. The trial is one of the great set pieces in all French history. So it's held in the palidogistis. It's packed. The Galleries are rammed with spectators. Massive anticipation. The prosecutor, I mean, you couldn't make this up. The prosecutor is Damonland's distant cousin.
无套裤汉耶稣基督站在本丢·彼拉多面前时一样的年龄。我是说，你可以看出，基本上，如果你站在丹东旁边，你会，你会提高你的水平，不是吗？你会提高你的机智水平。实际上接下来发生的事情，审判。审判是法国历史上最伟大的重头戏之一。所以它在司法宫举行。那里挤满了人。画廊里挤满了观众。巨大的期待。检察官，我是说，你编不出这个。检察官是德穆兰的远房表亲。
He's a guy called Fouquier-Tanville. And he's always described as the villain of the piece, that one of Stalin's prosecutors. But actually, I think that's a bit unfair. Most historians say Fouquier is actually quite a conscientious lawyer and a stickler for details, methodical, serious and stuff. and he completely fails to keep order. So people are shouting all the time from the galleries.
他叫富基耶-坦维尔。他总是被描述为这个故事中的反派，斯大林检察官之一。但实际上，我认为这有点不公平。大多数历史学家说富基耶实际上是一个相当认真的律师，是一个注重细节、有条理、严肃的人。但他完全没能维持秩序。所以人们一直在画廊里大喊大叫。
Danton, who's a very big man, is just treating this as a stage. He's like a kind of bull tossing dogs left, right and center. Completely. And he's so loud, everyone says he's got this Karen's voice. He's so loud that people are standing in the street outside, outside the building and they can still hear him. He says this on day one.
丹东，一个非常高大的人，只是把这当作一个舞台。他就像一头把狗扔来扔去的公牛。完全是这样。而且他声音很大，每个人都说他有这种卡伦的声音。他声音太大，以至于外面街道上的人，大楼外面的人都能听到他。他在第一天就说了这个。
men like me cannot be bought. On their brows are imprinted in in a faceable characters, the seal of liberty, the genius of republicanism, and I am accused of having crawled at the feet of vile despots. And the court president tries to cut him off by tinkling this little bell. And Dantan says, The voice of a man who has to defend both his life and honour must vanquish the sound of your little bell.
像我这样的人是买不到的。在他们的额头上印着不可磨灭的字符，自由的印记，共和主义的天才，而我被指控在卑鄙的暴君脚下爬行。法庭主席试图通过摇响这个小铃铛来打断他。丹东说，一个必须捍卫自己生命和荣誉的人的声音，必须战胜你那小铃铛的声音。
So that's day one. He's warming up. Day two is the turn of the defence. So Foucair's presented the indictment. At this point, Don't I is just an absolutely titanic form. He doesn't bother looking at the jury or at the judges. He does all of his remarks to the spectators. And he says, my friends, you will judge me when you have heard me.
所以那是第一天。他在热身。第二天是辩护的时间。所以富基耶提出了起诉书。在这一点上，丹东处于一种绝对泰坦式的状态。他甚至懒得看陪审团或法官。他所有的言论都是针对观众的。他说，我的朋友们，当你们听完我的话后，你们会评判我。
My voice will be heard, not just by you, but by all of France. And the world. And the world, exactly. He says, you know, where are my accusers? Where is Rob Spear? Where are the committees? that cowards who slander me but do not dare to attack me to my face. And at the end of the day, he ends with these absolutely magnificent lines.
我的声音会被听到，不仅是被你们，而且是被整个法国。还有世界。还有世界，正是如此。他说，你知道，我的指控者在哪里？罗伯斯庇尔在哪里？委员会在哪里？那些诽谤我却不敢当面攻击我的懦夫。在一天结束时，他以这些绝对宏伟的台词结束。
If ever I'm on trial for some driving offence or something, I'd like to think I'd go down like this. During the last two days, the court has got to know Danton. Tomorrow, he hopes to sleep in the bosom of glory. He has never asked for pardon. You will see him fly to the scaffold with his usual serenity and the calm of a clear conscience. Do you know, I almost want you to be arrested for a traffic offence.
如果我因为某种交通违规或其他什么事受审，我希望我能像这样结束。在过去的两天里，法庭已经了解了丹东。明天，他希望睡在荣耀的怀抱中。他从未请求宽恕。你们会看到他带着他通常的宁静和清白良心的平静飞向断头台。你知道，我几乎希望你因为交通违规而被捕。
Thanks. I can hear you deliver that peroration. Do you? The reality would be so banal. I'm so sorry. I'm a bit tired. So, for the authorities, this is a terrible embarrassment. And it's actually getting worse because at the beginning of day three,
谢谢。我能听到你发表那段结束语。是吗？现实会是如此平庸。我很抱歉。我有点累了。所以，对于当局来说，这是一个可怕的尴尬。而且实际上情况变得更糟，因为在第三天开始时，
Dantan says, I would like to call a long list of witnesses in my defense. And he has a huge list of deputies from the convention and even members of of the Committee of Public Safety. And the judges say, no, you can't call all of these people. And the crowds start hooting and shouting at them. And Fouquet-Tanville, the prosecutor, who is described by one witness's affolet, which means panicked, he scribbles and notes the Committee of Public Safety. And he says, look, this is totally out of control now.
丹东说，我想传唤一份长长的证人名单来为我辩护。他有一份来自国民公会甚至救国委员会成员的庞大代表名单。法官们说，不，你不能传唤所有这些人。人群开始对他们嘘声和叫喊。而检察官富基耶-坦维尔，被一位证人描述为“惊慌失措”，他在给救国委员会写便条。他说，看，现在完全失控了。
If we don't change the rules, I cannot guarantee that we will get Danton's conviction. And Sanjoust rushes to the convention, and he says, we have a national emergency. I have to say this is shameless from Saint-Just. We've all been talking about his, you know, their rigid principles and their belief in their own virtue and they really sincere and all this. But this, I cannot be sincere. This is cynical. San Jus says, Dantan's allies in the prisons are planning a mass breakout and they're going to murder members of the convention. And actually, Daminglein's wife, Lucille, is in on it. She's one of the organizers. That's not gallant, is it? It's not good from Sajus. And Sanjouin,
如果我们不改变规则，我不能保证我们会得到丹东的有罪判决。圣茹斯特冲向国民公会，他说，我们有国家紧急状态。我不得不说，这对圣茹斯特来说是无耻的。我们一直在谈论他的，你知道，他们僵化的原则和他们对自身美德的信仰，他们真的很真诚，所有这些。但这，我不能真诚。这是愤世嫉俗的。圣茹斯特说，丹东在监狱里的盟友正在策划大规模越狱，他们要谋杀国民公会的成员。实际上，德穆兰的妻子露西尔也参与其中。她是组织者之一。那不绅士，不是吗？这对圣茹斯特来说不好。圣茹斯特，
just goes on to say, look at the way Dantan is behaving in the courtroom, shouting, dominating all of this. Doesn't that prove he's guilty? What innocent man ever revolted against the law? I mean, a chilling sentiment. Basically defend yourself. It proves you're guilty. And the Convention approves an emergency decree that the prosecutors can remove defendants from the courtroom if their behavior insults the justice of the nation. That same day, by the way, the Committee of General security issues of warrant for Lucille de Moulin's arrest as well, to DeMille's wife. Now, she in the interim had written Rob Spierre a very moving letter, reminding him of their old friendship and how important he'd been to their family.
接着说，看看丹东在法庭上的表现，大喊大叫，主宰这一切。这难道不能证明他有罪吗？哪个无辜的人曾经反抗过法律？我是说，一种令人不寒而栗的情绪。基本上为自己辩护。这证明你有罪。国民公会批准了一项紧急法令，如果被告的行为侮辱了国家的正义，检察官可以将他们从法庭上带走。顺便说一句，就在同一天，治安委员会也签发了逮捕露西尔·德穆兰的逮捕令，即德穆兰的妻子。现在，她在此期间给罗伯斯庇尔写了一封非常感人的信，提醒他他们过去的友谊以及他对他们家庭的重要性。
She said to him, do you think the people will respect you for destroying your friends? Do you think they will bless somebody who doesn't care about a widow's tears or an orphan's plight? And she even went to Rob Spire's house that Robespier refused to see. I mean, the thing is that for Robespierre, this is the index of his virtue, because he is genuinely distraught at the thought of them dying. Yeah, I'm such a kind person, I'm killing my friends. Well, but, you know, who would you betray your friends or your country? He's betraying his friends. Yeah, exactly. So in the meantime, Fouquet-Tanville now has what he needs. The next morning,
她对他说，你认为人民会因为你摧毁你的朋友而尊重你吗？你认为他们会祝福一个不在乎寡妇的眼泪或孤儿的困境的人吗？她甚至去了罗伯斯庇尔的家，但罗伯斯庇尔拒绝见面。我是说，问题在于对罗伯斯庇尔来说，这是他美德的指标，因为他确实对他们死亡的想法感到心烦意乱。是的，我是个如此善良的人，我正在杀我的朋友。好吧，但是，你知道，你会背叛你的朋友还是你的国家？他正在背叛他的朋友。是的，正是如此。与此同时，富基耶-坦维尔现在有了他需要的东西。第二天早上，
the 5th of April, Danton and Coe are removed from the court. They're dragged out, and as they're dragged out, Dantantz shouts furiously. He says, we're going to be judged without being heard. And then he says very mockingly, you know, go on, take us to the scaffold. Fugier says to the jury, I believe you've heard all you need to. Can you make your decision? The sentence is, of course, death. As they're waiting in the Luxembourg prison, Dantan seems rueful. He's actually quite wry. He says, funny thing is none of those people know anything about government. If I left my balls to Rob Spierreau and my legs to coot on. the Committee of Public Safety might last a bit longer.
4月5日，丹东等人被从法庭带走。他们被拖了出去，当他们被拖出去时，丹东愤怒地大喊。他说，我们将在不被听取的情况下被审判。然后他非常嘲讽地说，你知道，继续，带我们去断头台。富基耶对陪审团说，我相信你们已经听到了你们需要的一切。你们能做出决定吗？判决当然是死刑。当他们在卢森堡监狱等待时，丹东似乎很后悔。他实际上相当讽刺。他说，有趣的是，那些人对政府一无所知。如果我把我的胆量留给罗伯斯庇尔，把我的腿留给库东，救国委员会可能会持续更久。
I think that's a very good line. Damoulin, however, is crushed at the thought of parting from his wife Lucille. He doesn't know at this point that she has been arrested. And he writes to this last letter, very affecting, one of the most well-known letters in French history. My Lucille, my darling, despite my torment, I believe there is a God. One day I will see you again. Adieu, lulu. Adieu, my life, my soul, my goddess on earth.
我认为那是一句非常好的台词。然而，德穆兰在想到要与妻子露西尔分离时崩溃了。他此时不知道她已经被捕了。他写了这封最后的信，非常感人，法国历史上最著名的信件之一。我的露西尔，我的亲爱的，尽管我受尽折磨，但我相信有一个上帝。有一天我会再见到你。再见，露露。再见，我的生命，我的灵魂，我尘世的女神。
I feel the shores of life receding before me. I see you again, Lucille. I see my arms around you. My tied hands embrace you. My severed head rests its eyes on you. But she never actually gets to read it because she has now been locked up as well. So late that afternoon, they are taken to the guillotine. Dusk is falling.
我感到生命之岸在我面前退去。我再见到你，露西尔。我看到我的双臂拥抱着你。我被绑的双手拥抱着你。我被砍下的头颅用眼睛看着你。但她实际上永远没能读到它，因为她现在也被关起来了。所以那天下午晚些时候，他们被带到了断头台。黄昏正在降临。
You described the scene, the eyewitness account. Des Molyne, just before he was executed, was told that his wife had been arrested and he was devastated. He fought with the executionist on the scaffold until the shirt had almost been ripped from his body and they have to force him into the guillotine. And then d'Anton goes last. He cuts this incredibly defiant figure, that amazing last line.
你描述了那个场景，目击者的描述。德穆兰在被处决前不久，被告知他的妻子已经被捕，他崩溃了。他在断头台上与刽子手搏斗，直到衬衫几乎从他身上被撕下来，他们不得不强行把他推上断头台。然后丹东最后一个。他表现出这种令人难以置信的挑衅姿态，那句惊人的最后台词。
Don't forget to show my head to the people. It'll be worth it. You know, a very fitting epitaph. And finally, Lucille de Milance, she was guillotined a week later and she wrote a very affecting last letter to her mother before she died. Good night, dear Mamma.
别忘了把我的头展示给人们看。这会很值得。你知道，这可是非常贴切的墓志铭。最后，露西尔·德·米朗斯，她在一周后被送上了断头台，她在临死前给母亲写了一封非常感人的遗书。晚安，亲爱的妈妈。
A tear falls from my eyes. It is for you. I am going to sleep in the tranquility of innocence. So that's that. Danton's dead and Robespierre and the committees have won. And on the face of it, Robespierre now appeals unassailable. And he and his allies have crushed their critics
一滴泪从我眼中滑落。那是为你而流。我将在纯真的宁静中长眠。事情就是这样。丹东死了，罗伯斯庇尔和委员会赢了。表面上看，罗伯斯庇尔现在似乎不可动摇。他和他的盟友们已经粉碎了批评者，
and they've sent a clear message that basically any challenge will not be tolerated. However, inside the committees, it's clear there is now a mood of deep suspicion. So the army guy, Carnot, later said that spring, so let's say March, April, we had to move our meetings to a different room so that people would not be able to observe the storms that agitated us. And of course, in the convention, if you're one of the deputies, and you've just seen Ebert on, as it were, the left go to the guillotine, and you've seen Dantton on the more moderate wing go to the guillotine. you know, if they can both go, anyone can. Who's to say you're safe?
并传达了一个明确的信息，即基本上任何挑战都不会被容忍。然而，在委员会内部，显然现在弥漫着一种深深的怀疑情绪。所以那位军方人士卡诺后来提到，那个春天，也就是三四月份，我们不得不把会议搬到另一个房间，以免人们观察到我们之间激烈的争吵。当然，在国民公会里，如果你是代表之一，你刚刚看到左翼的埃贝尔被送上断头台，又看到温和派的丹东被送上断头台，你知道，如果他们两个都能被处决，任何人都有可能。谁敢说你是安全的呢？
And actually, even at this point, with Rob Spierre, apparently at his peak, there are signs that this cannot last and people who think this can't last. And there's a story that when Danton was on his way to the guillotine in the tumbril, he looked up as they went past Robespier's house, and he said almost to himself, you will soon be following. us. They will tear your house down and they will sow the ground with salt. And as we will see, he was not wrong. Thank you, Dominic. The stage is now set for the climax of this series, the dramatic final weeks of the reign of terror. So next week, two episodes to finish this series.
事实上，即使在这一点上，罗伯斯庇尔看似处于巅峰时期，也有迹象表明这种情况无法持久，也有人认为这无法持久。有一个故事说，当丹东在囚车上前往断头台的路上，经过罗伯斯庇尔家时，他抬头看了一眼，几乎是自言自语地说，你很快就会跟随我们了。他们会拆毁你的房子，并在地上撒盐。正如我们将要看到的，他并没有说错。谢谢你，多米尼克。现在舞台已经为本系列的最高潮做好了准备，即恐怖统治最后几周的戏剧性时刻。所以下周，我们将用两集来结束这个系列。
First of all, the apotheosis of Robespierre as he climbs yet another Papier-Mashe mountain to celebrate the festival of the Supreme Being, a very, I mean, kind of one of the most bizarre episodes in the whole of the French Revolution. And then the last episode, it's the final showdown as the convention turns on Robespierre and the revolution destroys its favorite son. And club members, of course, you can go ahead, hear those episodes right away. And if you are not a member of the club and you'd like to join them, then sign up at the rest of history.com. And on Wednesday, very excitingly, club members will get a very special bonus, a discussion about the French Revolution with one of its best-known chroniclers. The great historian, Simon Sharma.
首先是罗伯斯庇尔的“神化”，他爬上一座又一座纸糊的山峰来庆祝最高主宰节，这简直是整个法国大革命中最离奇的事件之一。然后是最后一集，那是最终的摊牌，国民公会反戈一击对付罗伯斯庇尔，革命摧毁了它最宠爱的儿子。当然，俱乐部成员们，你们可以现在就去收听这些剧集。如果你还不是俱乐部成员，想要加入他们，请在therestisistory.com注册。周三，非常令人兴奋的是，俱乐部成员将获得一个特别福利，即与法国大革命最著名的记录者之一、伟大的历史学家西蒙·沙马进行一场关于法国大革命的讨论。
Ovoire. Avoir. Is history anything more than the story of heroes and villains? Of course it is, but not in our brand new The Rest is History book, a history of the world in 51 heroes and villains. Now in this book, we have picked out some of our very favourite characters from the last few years of The Rest is History. So we've got Genghis Khan, we have Cyrus the Great,
再见。历史难道仅仅是英雄和恶棍的故事吗？当然不止于此，但在我们全新的《历史的其余部分》一书中，即《51位英雄与恶棍的世界史》，我们挑选了过去几年《历史的其余部分》中我们最喜欢的一些人物。所以我们有成吉思汗，有居鲁士大帝，
we have Marianne Tuanette, and obviously we have Brian Jones. of the Rolling Stones. Now, some of these people are friends of the show, some of them are unwanted acquaintances, some of them are downright foes of the show. But we had one rule. They had to be interesting, and there had to be interesting stories about them. So, now is your chance to pick aside, to polish your armour, to don your very best First World War General's moustache, and to decide whether you are on the side of the heroes or the villains. A history of the history. A of the world in 51 heroes and villains is available now. It makes a wonderful Christmas present. I cannot recommend it to you more highly. If you don't buy a copy, you will probably regret it
有玛丽·安托瓦内特，当然还有滚石乐队的布莱恩·琼斯。这些人中，有些是节目的朋友，有些是不受欢迎的熟人，有些甚至是节目的死对头。但我们有一个原则：他们必须有趣，而且必须有关于他们的有趣故事。所以，现在是你选择立场的时候了，擦亮你的盔甲，戴上你最好的第一次世界大战将军胡子，决定你是站在英雄一边还是恶棍一边。《51位英雄与恶棍的世界史》现已上市。它是一份很棒的圣诞礼物。我强烈推荐给你们。如果你不买一本，你可能会后悔
until the day you die. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
直到你死的那一天。再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。